bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur public sénat voici le programme de
votre après-midi le sénat rouvre le
débat sur la prescription à des crimes à
sexuels sur les mineurs on retrouvera
thème tran huy en direct de l'hémicycle
dans un instant et puis à 19 heures je
vous retrouve pour 24 heures sénat le
journal mais l'actualité au sénat c'est
aussi ce sont aussi ces nouvelles
révélations du canard enchaîné sur les
soupçons de détournement de fonds du
groupe ump selon le canard enchaîné les
responsables de la trésorerie du groupe
ump aurait donné l'ordre de détruire la
comptabilité des deux des deux
associations au coeur de cette affaire
on y reviendra tout à l'heure dans notre
journal le sénat a adopté hier par
290 voix contre 44 une proposition de
loi constitutionnelle pour modifier la
charte de l'environnement ce texte
présenté par l'ump réaffirment que le
principe de précaution est aussi un
principe d'innovation il doit à présent
recevoir l'aval de l'assemblée nationale
je vous le disais la haute-assemblée
examine cet après midi une proposition
de loi pour mieux juger les auteurs des
crimes sexuels en modifiant la
prescription car il n'est pas rare que
certaines victimes qui ont subi des
viols pendant leur enfance ne prenne
conscience des faits qu'à l'âge adulte
il est alors trop tard pour condamner
leurs agresseurs écoutez ce témoignage
douloureux recueillis par nathalie
guelwaar aujourd'hui j'ai été violée la
première fois dix sept mois sur mon lit
d'hôpital
comment je peux savoir que c'est à 17
mois tout simplement parce que la date
figure sur mon carnet de santé ça s'est
passé durant une hospitalisation
et l'agresseur a été mon grand-père
pédiatre qui était celui qui m'avait
fait hospitaliser j'ai été violée
ensuite à 5 ans par le curé du village
où j'habitais et puis ensuite de 8 ans
11 ans et demi par mon père mon père
arrêté à 11 ans et demi parce que c'est
moment j'ai eu mes règles
j'ai tout oublié toute amnésie et je ne
me souvenais plus de rien jusqu'à 42 ans
la nuit du 13 au 14 novembre 2012 j'ai
fait ce qu'on appelle une décompensation
psychique mais dans sont mises à claques
et de terreur et mon corps est parti en
enfer j'ai retrouvé toutes les
sensations kinesthésique des viols
survécu les scènes des viols avec toutes
les émotions liées la terreur
la folle il envie de mourir l'espace
dans la poitrine les nausées
et puis il y avait surtout le visage de
mon père très au dessus de moi pas le
visage de mon père aujourd'hui le visage
qu'ils avaient quand il avait 40 ans pas
du tout dégarnie avec tous ses cheveux
est très au dessus de moi et ses yeux
sont des trous noirs et je voyais aussi
les trous de son nez ses narines comme
des trous noirs par en dessous parce que
c'était la première chose que je voyais
la nuit quand il venait me réveiller
pour violer c'est elle et les trous de
son nez par en dessous
alors on va tout de suite se retrouver
thème tran huy en direct de l'hémicycle
alors tam a les discussions ont commencé
alors que proposent les élus centristes
sur cette question à des crimes sexuels
écoutez les élus centristes chantal
jouanno et made in heaven modifier la
prescription en matière de crime sexuel
alors pour donner un exemple aujourd'hui
une victime mineure de viol à 20 ans
pour porter plainte mais elle a 20 ans à
partir du moment où les faits se sont
déroulés or souvent les enfants victimes
de viol sont aussi touchés par une
amnésie traumatique il refoule ses
souvenirs et parfois ses souvenirs ne
reviennent que 30 ou 40 ans plus tard et
donc trop tard alors face à cette
situation les sénatrices veulent que et
bien le délai de prescription commence
non pas à partir du moment où ont eu
lieu les faits mais à partir du moment
ou bien où les victimes et bien se sont
rendu compte que ces faits ont eu lieu
mais voilà ce cette proposition se
confronte à plusieurs problèmes d'abord
un problème juridique parce que cela
revient plus ou moins à rendre ce crime
imprescriptible
or en france de législateur est là
dessus très clair seul le crime contre
l'humanité imprescriptibles
mais là-dessus pourrait-il y avoir une
solution puisque un amendement
socialiste propose simplement de
rallonger le délai de prescription de
dix ans mais l'autre problème celui là
elle demeurera toujours c'est que 30 aux
quarante ans plus tard où sont les
preuves où sont les témoignages il ya
donc réellement un problème puisque les
victimes qu'ils porteraient plainte ne
verrait pas forcément leur parole
écoutée et leurs bourreaux condamné ce
qui reviendrait à les rendre victime une
seconde fois merci beaucoup tam alors je
vous propose est bien tout de suite de
suivre cette séance avec l'intervention
de muguette dini sénatrice udi uc du
rhône est à l'origine avec chantal
jouanno de cette proposition de loi
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues tout d'abord je tiens à
vous remercier monsieur le président de
la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur d'avoir permis
que ce texte arrive en séance dans sa
version initiale
pour mieux vous faire comprendre chers
collègues le sens de ma proposition de
loi je vais vous lire le témoignage de
deux victimes et vous demande pour ce
faire toute votre attention
le premier témoignage et celui d'ariane
haut fonctionnaire dans un ministère et
présente cet après midi dans les
tribunes ce qu'elles racontent des
événements survenus dans sa petite
enfance est si violent que je n'ai pas
souhaité vous en donner lecture il faut
seulement savoir que ces événements sont
confirmées par des mentions dans son
carnet de santé et des précisions
apportées par sa mère je tiens par
contre à lui donner la parole concernant
son père il m'a violée entre 8 ans et 11
ans et demi ça s'est arrêté parce qu'à
partir de ce moment là j'aurais pu me
retrouver enceinte à 10 ans j'ai fait
une tentative de suicide par
électrocution j'ai amené zié tous ses
vols et ma tentative de suicide et ne
m'en suis souvenu qu'à 42 ans dans la
nuit du 13 au 14 novembre 1912 trente
longues années où je n'ai pas vécu mais
où j'ai survécu dissocier et saccagé à
toutes les tortures que j'avais subi fin
de citation le deuxième témoignage et
celui d'olivier 52 ans pilote d'affaires
et instructeurs qui se souvient
pensionnaire dans un établissement
religieux j'ai subi à 10 ans des
violences sexuelles graves assortis de
tortures de la part d'un surveillant
laïque quand j'ai quitté cet
établissement pour entrer au collège
j'ai décidé que plus jamais je ne me
laisserais faire je me suis procuré une
carabine démontable toujours à portée de
main y compris à l'école j'ai enfoui
tout cela n'en ai jamais parlé à mes
parents ses souvenirs sont remontés à la
surface quarante ans plus tard en
retrouvant des camarades sur les réseaux
sociaux je me rends compte maintenant
des effets délétères de ces agressions
colère extrême
surréaction face à des événements
anodins perte de confiance en moi désir
d'autodestruction fin de citation
olivier est aussi dans les tribunes avec
d'autres victimes hommes et femmes il
existe même une association de joueurs
de rugby les colosses aux pieds d'argile
dont tous les membres ont été victimes
de violences sexuelles dans leur enfance
depuis le dépôt de notre proposition de
loi chantal jouanno et moi même avons
réussi reçu de multiples témoignages par
lettre ou par mail y compris d'une
personne travaillant ici au sénat toute
victime trop âgé pour être entendu par
la police ou la gendarmerie
toutes espèrent que cette loi sera votée
il ne s'agit donc pas de cas
exceptionnels mais d'un véritable fléau
très répandue dont beaucoup d'entre nous
commencent à peine à prendre conscience
les chiffres sont parlants on estime
qu'une femme sur quatre soit 25% et un
homme sur six soit 17% ont été victimes
de violences sexuelles et ceci
principalement dans l'enfance les
chiffres officiels communiqués par les
services de police et de gendarmerie
font état en 2012 de 10300 violences
sexuelles viols agressions et
harcèlement sur majeur et de 16000
violences sexuelles sur mineurs c'est la
partie émergée de l'iceberg car les
chiffres officiels de l'institut
national des hautes études de la
sécurité et de la justice font état sur
une population de 18 à 75 ans en moyenne
chaque année de 280000 violences
sexuelles hors ménage de 850000
violences physiques ou sexuelles intra
ménages de 190000 viol ou tentative de
viol ce qui fait or violence intra
ménage entre couples
470000 agressions sexuelles à comparer
aux 600 50 homicides par an et dans
cette enquête il faut le souligner les
mineurs ne sont pas interrogés par
ailleurs dans l'étude de nathalie bajos
et michel bozon 16% des femmes et 5 %
des hommes rapportent des agressions
sexuelles dans leur vie alors que les
mineurs là encore n'ont pas été
interrogés enfin la seule étude
française réalisée auprès des jeunes
avec une méthodologie scientifique l'a
été en 2007 dans le monde du sport après
les révélations des vols des joues des
viols des joueuses de tennis cette étude
montre qu'un sportif interrogée sur
trois a été victime de violences
sexuelles et dans une proportion
sensiblement équivalente pour les
garçons et pour les filles
les chiffres de la violence sexuelle en
possession du ministère de l'éducation
nationale pour l'instant confidentiel
mais dont nous avons pu avoir
connaissance montre l'étendue des dégâts
dans les établissements scolaires autre
facette de la violence sexuelle liées
entre autres à la pornographie très
présente sur les terminaux de nos
enfants il est intéressant de noter que
début mai le vatican a fourni des
chiffres
3420 situation taxés accusations
crédibles ont été examinés au cours des
dix dernières années portant sur des
actes commis entre 1950 et 1980 quand on
parle de 3,4 3420 situation crédible on
parle de 3420 prédateurs dont on ignore
bien sur le nombre de victimes et si ce
chiffre paraît faible c'est que là
encore c'est la partie émergée de
l'iceberg
l'ensemble de ces chiffres ne concernent
pas spécifiquement les mineurs alors que
la majorité des agressions sexuelles
sont perpétrés sur des enfants qui sont
les premiers à souffrir d'amnésie post
traumatique je le répète pour la
troisième fois c'est la partie émergée
de l'iceberg
ce sont des dizaines de milliers
d'enfants qui sont victimes d'agressions
sexuelles
tous les jours dans notre pays ceci
incluant les agressions répétées dont la
plupart des enfants sont victimes
pourquoi ces victimes ne parle-t-elle
pas alors qu'elle pourrait dénoncer les
faits quand ils se produisent ou encore
pendant 10 ans ou 20 ans après leur
majorité suivant la gravité des actes
soit avant d'atteindre l'âge de 28 ans
ou de 38 ans c'est là que nous
constatons notre ignorance sur les
effets produits par ces violences
comment des violences aussi graves ont
elles pu être occultés ou ça ment
sciemment connu mais non dit par des
victimes pendant aussi longtemps pour
comprendre nous avons besoin des
spécialistes et j'emprunterai mes
explications au docteur violaine guérin
gynécologue et endocrinologues qui dans
sa pratique a rencontré de multiples
situations
aboutissant à des symptômes très
fréquents et très comparable je la cite
il est extrêmement complexe pour une
personne non familières avec le sujet
des violences sexuelles de comprendre
comment des violences aussi graves
peuvent être occultée par les victimes à
cela une multitude de raisons possibles
dont les plus fréquentes sont les
suivantes un viol est un événement
extrêmement violents au cours duquel
perdre connaissance n'est pas rare la
mémorisation d'un événement traumatique
quel qu'il soit peut-être déficiente car
le cerveau n'a pas le temps d'imprimer
l'événement à l'exemple d'une personne
renversée par une voiture qui n'a pas
mémoriser le traumatisme et a aussi
oublié ce qu'elle faisait les minutes
précédentes un viol est de plus en plus
souvent réalisés chez des personnes
alcoolisées ou drogué qui n'ont plus le
souvenir de ce qui s'est passé mais peut
aussi être effacées de la mémoire chez
un enfant que l'on adore aller terre ou
par des médicaments un viol peut être
refoulé au sens du déni et le plus
souvent un viol n'est pas conscientiser
comme tel en particulier chez l'enfant
qui a tendance à faire confiance à
l'adulte et a pour seul cadre de
référence sa famille il n'est donc pas
en mesure de définir ce qu'on lui fait
fin de citation
les conséquences sont effrayantes dit le
docteur guy férez de montpellier
médecins généralistes qui a été aussi
médecin humanitaire en afghanistan et au
nigeria et qui est spécialiste des
violences sexuelles
voici ce qu'il dit des conséquences
pathologie psychique repli honte
culpabilité
anxiété dépression suicide pathologies
de la vie sexuelle pathologie somatiques
nombreuses est encore mal connue
relations humaines a minima ou distordue
secrets de famille récurrence
transgénérationnel passage à l'acte en
tant qu'agresseur on comprend mieux
qu'il faille du temps et quelques fois
beaucoup de temps pour que les victimes
parlent
pourquoi est il indispensable que cette
verbalisation se fasse auprès des
pouvoirs publics
en portant plainte contre son agresseur
pour quatre raisons aussi essentiel les
unes que les autres la victime a besoin
d'être reconnus comme tels la victime a
besoin d'être aidé pour aller mieux
psychologiquement et physiquement et en
conséquence compte tenu du nombre de
victimes pour que notre société aille
mieux aussi la victime veut empêcher son
prédateur de faire d'autres victimes
et l'auteur doit être identifié
sanctionné et ou soigner nous n'avons
pas le droit de faire semblant de ne
rien savoir en ne prenant pas en compte
les dénonciations des faits plus de
vingt ans après la majorité
l'objectif de cette proposition de loi
est de donner aux victimes le temps de
conscientiser l'ordre leur traumatisme
le courage de le révéler et la maturité
pour assurer assumer les conséquences de
cette révélation
l'association stop aux violences
sexuelles milite pour mettre en place
une meilleure évaluation des agressions
sexuelles un plan de prévention et de
soins aux victimes et aux agresseurs
elle milite ainsi pour une obligation de
soin aux auteurs soutenu par des
protocoles pertinents avec comme
objectif la diminution à terme du nombre
des infractions temps du fait des soins
appliqués aux victimes dont un certain
nombre de vienne hauteur que des soins
aux auteurs dont un grand nombre ont été
victimes mais en attendant que tout ceci
se mette en place et je n'ai aucun doute
sur la réalisation de ce projet il est
nécessaire de donner la parole et
d'écouté ceux et celles qui souffrent
les victimes voilà pourquoi il m'a
semblé nécessaire de déposer cette
proposition de loi qui a pour objet
objet d'établir un strict parallélisme
entre le régime de prescription des
crimes et agressions sexuelles et le
régime de prescription
appliquée aux abus de biens sociaux et
aux abus de confiance puisque ces
infractions ont en commun un mécanisme
de dissimulation la particularité des
abus de biens sociaux réside dans le
fait qu'ils sont par essence d
infraction clandestine
de sorte que la cour de cassation en
consacrant leur caractère souterrain à
imposer une jurisprudence qui fait
courir le délai de prescription de trois
ans à partir de la date de la révélation
de la vue et non de la date où celui ci
a été commis cette clandestinité se
retrouvent dans les violences sexuelles
qui en raison de leur nature du
traumatisme qu'elles entraînent et de la
situation de vulnérabilité particulière
dans laquelle elle place les victimes
peuvent faire l'objet d'une prise de
conscience ou d'une révélation tardive
un report du point dès l'es2 du point de
départ du délai de prescription au jour
où l'infraction apparaît à la victime
dans des conditions permettant
l'exercice de l'action publique c'est à
dire au jour du dépôt de plainte
consacrerait au regard des règles de
prescription une égalité de traitement
gage de sécurité juridique entre toutes
les infractions souterraine commises
tant contre les biens qu'à l'encontre
dès personnes
au cours de mes rencontres ces derniers
temps il m'a été dit que cette
formulation le jour où l'infraction
apparaît à la victime dans les
conditions permettant l'exercice de
l'action publique
reprise de la jurisprudence sur les abus
de biens sociaux pouvaient prêter à
confusion j'ai donc déposé un amendement
qui précise très clairement que les
délais de prescription doivent courir à
partir du moment où la vie active la
victime porte plainte
pour conclure je compléterai le
témoignage d'ariane
la première personne que j'ai évoqués
j'ai déposé plainte contre mon père en
septembre 2013 j'avais quarante trois
ans soit cinq ans trop tard pour être
dans les délais de prescription
je la cite c'est trop tard ils disent
mais mon corps vient juste de s'en
souvenir c'est prescrit ils disent mais
dans mon corps ce n'est pas prescrit
alors aujourd'hui je demande justice ou
législateur de mon pays pour que la pour
la petite fille que j'ai été et j'y
ajouterai celui de cécile qui a fait la
une des journaux et qui est elle aussi
dans les tribunes violée à l'âge de 5
ans par un cousin de 38 ans le souvenir
lui en est revenu avec une grande
précision lors d'une séance d'hypnose
trop tard pour porter plainte
puisqu'elle avait plus de 38 ans elle a
déposé un recours devant la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
que sa plainte soit prise en compte
malgré le délai de prescription
cette plainte a peu de chances d'aboutir
elle explique sa révolte
lorsque les souvenirs des viols sont
remontées à ma mémoire je les airs vécu
dans ma chair avec une violence inouïe
comme si je revivais ce crime une
deuxième fois les scènes de fait ont
explosé à ma conscience avec des détails
si précis que j'avais l'impression
d'avoir une caméra à la main c'est parce
que la résurgence de ces souvenirs et
d'une telle violence que le besoin de
réparations judiciaire est criant et ce
quel que soit le nombre des années
écoulées pour les victimes d'amnésie
traumatique la prescription ce droit à
l'oubli ça ne peut pas exister
fin de citation
toutes les victimes le cri ne nous
abandonnez pas laissez nous le temps de
parler entendez nous aidez nous aidez
nous à empêcher notre prédateurs de
nuire encore on objecte fréquemment
qu'il sera bien difficile si tardivement
d'apporter la preuve des violences
sexuelles à cette objection je serai de
réponse est il plus facile d'établir la
preuve quand la victime porte plainte à
37 ans et 11 mois qu'à 38 ans et trois
jours
il ne faut pas oublier que beaucoup
d'auteurs sont des prédateurs qui auront
fait et qui font encore d'autres
victimes qu'on pourra retrouver par
ailleurs si la qualité des expertises
médicales j10 hier s'améliore le
problème des preuves ne se posera plus
ou très peu le groupe de médecins et le
groupe juridique de l'association svs
travaille activement à établir un
dossier type d' expertise on me dit
aussi que si le parcours judiciaire
n'aboutit pas la victime sera encore
plus traumatisé les professionnels de la
réparation et les victimes elles mêmes
rétorque que l'échec de la procédure
judiciaire est moins douloureux que
l'impossibilité d'y avoir recours
il ne faut pas non plus négliger la
douleur et la culpabilité des victimes
qui n'auront pas su ou pas pu protéger
d'autres enfants ou d'autres adultes des
méfaits de l'auteur de leur traumatisme
mes chers collègues ne laissez pas ces
appels sans réponse je connais les
arguments pour uniformiser un droit de
prescription moderne et cohérent c'est
le titre de rapports de messieurs y est
portelli & young en 2007 mais je note
aussi que la recommandation de ce
rapport la recommandation numéro 5 dit
qu'il faut je cite consacrer dans la loi
la jurisprudence de la cour de cassation
tendant pour les infractions occulter
dissimulé a repoussé le point de départ
du délai de près de prescription au jour
où l'infraction est révélée et étendre
cette solution à d'autres infractions
occultes et dissimulés dans d'autres
domaines du droit pénal et en
particulier en matière criminelle je
vous demande chers collègues de ne pas
attendre d'avoir fait la liste des
autres infractions que vous évoquez dans
cette recommandation est d'aligner dès
aujourd'hui les prescriptions des
violences sexuelles sur celle des délits
de biens sociaux ne laissez pas les
victimes plus longtemps dans le
désespoir
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à monsieur philippe
kaltenbach rapporteur de la commission
des lois
monsieur le président madame la
secrétaire d'état monsieur le président
de la commission des lois mes chers
collègues
la présente proposition de loi déposée
par mesdames dini et jouanno tend à
modifier le délai de prescription de
l'action publique pour les agressions
sexuelles
nos deux collègues partent du constat
que ces délais de prescription qui sont
appliquées ou violences sexuelles en
france sont inadaptés c'est vrai que
m'indigner a fait une belle
démonstration et on ne peut qu'être
touché par la force de ses arguments
aussi celle ci nous propose de replacer
la victime ou centre de dispositifs et
de ne faire commencer à courir le délai
de prescription des viols et agressions
sexuelles aggravées qu'à compter du
moment où la victime est en mesure de
révéler la fraction
pour ce faire le dispositif présenté
s'inspire du régime je reste
prudentielles applicables aux
infractions occultes ou dissimulé pour
lesquels le délai de prescription
commence à courir au jour où
l'infraction est apparu et a pu être
constaté dans des conditions permettant
l'exercice de l'action publique
cette proposition de loi si elle
concerne l'ensemble des victimes
d'agressions sexuelles ou de viols
s'adresse prioritairement et on l'a vu à
travers les citations des témoignages
pour les victimes ayant subi ces
agressions ou ces viols
lorsqu'elle était enfant
le choc émotionnel subit tout
particulièrement lorsque les faits ont
été commis dans la durée par un parent
ou une personne ayant autorité sur
l'enfant est en effet de nature à
provoquer un traumatisme profond
pouvant aller jusqu'à la plus parfaite
amnésie
on qualifie cette amnésie d' amnésie
post-traumatique
et ce constat clinique qui est c'est
vrai encore méconnu est aujourd'hui très
bien documenté j'ai eu l'occasion
lors de mes auditions d'entendre des
professeurs et des médecins qui me l'ont
confirmé
à cet égard les délais de prescription
applicables aux infractions sexuelles
commis sur des mineures peuvent donc
apparaître inadapté lorsque les faits
commis ressurgissent brutalement dans
les mains de la victime de nombreuses
années après
le dispositif actuellement existants
dans le droit pénal français réprime
sévèrement les violences sexuelles je
crois qu'il faut le rappeler et cette
proposition de loi vise les délais de
prescription et non les peines
aujourd'hui en france l'auteur d'un viol
encourt 15 ans de réclusion criminelle
et même 20 ans lorsque les faits sont
commis avec circonstances aggravantes
les autres agressions sexuelles sont en
principe publiques de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement ces peines pouvant être
porté à 10 ans notamment lorsque la
victime est un mineur de 15 ans et on
constate à travers les statistiques du
casier judiciaire la fermeté des peines
prononcées à l'encontre des auteurs
reconnus coupables de viols et
d'agressions sexuelles
cela dit et cela a été pointé par madame
vie ni
les affaires qui se termine en justice
ne sont que la partie immergée de
l'iceberg et correspondent peut être à
moins de 10% du total des viols et
violences que subissent nos concitoyens
chaque année le nombre de condamnations
inscrites au casier judiciaire s'établit
en moyenne à
7000 8000 par an alors que lors de l'
enquête conjointe menée par l'insee et
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance en 2012 sur les personnes
âgées de 18 à 115 ans il a été recensé
sur ces deux années
quatre cent mille personnes ayant été
victimes de violences sexuelles en 2010
ou 2011 ce qui fait deux cent mille par
an
venons en maintenant aux actuels délai
de prescription
afin de tenir compte
des difficultés particulières
rencontrées par les mineurs pour
dénoncer des faits de viols et d'abus
sexuels le législateur a progressivement
allongé le délai de prescription
applicable à certains crimes et délits
commis sur les mineurs
le premier acte a été l'adoption le 10
juillet 1989 d'une loi qui a précisé que
les délais courts et à partir de la
majorité de la victime depuis 1989 il ya
eu six modifications législatives qui
sont intervenus mais j'y fais référence
mon rapport et au terme de six de ses
sites modifications dont la dernière
remonte à 2004 le délai de prescription
de l'action publique dé viol a été porté
à vingt ans après la majorité de la
victime
ce qui fait donc dix huit ans + 20 ans
38 ans
les autres agressions sexuelles et actes
sexuels contre les mineurs ont un délai
de prescription de l'action publique
portait à 10 ans après la majorité
la question qui est posée aujourd'hui un
homme digne il a très bien fait et
simple
aujourd'hui dix ans après l'adoption de
la loi de 2004 ces délais de
prescription sont ils adaptés sont ils
suffisants et c'est sur cette question
que nous devons travailler et trouver la
meilleure solution possible
vous le savez pour les victimes majeures
les délais sont les délais commun pour
les prescriptions trois ans pour les
agressions dix ans pour les viols
il y à cette spécificité pour les
mineurs
et cette spécificité
je crois a été voulue en 2004 pour
justement permettre à des enfants qui
ont été violées de pouvoir porter
plainte lorsque la maturité de victime
et son détachement du lien familial
puisque souvent ces violences sans être
à familial lui permettait de porter
plainte et donc de révéler les faits de
fait l'emprise exercée par l'auteur des
faits le sentiment de culpabilité dont
souffre la victime la complicité de
l'entourage
c'est vrai mais malheureusement parfois
le dénigrement systématique de la parole
de l'enfant sont autant d'obstacles à la
parole de la victime et puis de façon
plus générale il y a toujours un
sentiment de honte et d'humiliation qui
touche toutes les victimes de violences
sexuelles et cela constitue un obstacle
majeur à la dénonciation des faits et
explique en partie la faiblesse du taux
de plaintes
ces obstacles à la parole des victimes
sont toutefois à mon sens à distinguer
du phénomène d'amnésie traumatique déjà
évoqué précédemment et dont souffrent
certaines victimes à la suite d'un choc
émotionnel profond
ce mécanisme qui établit sur le plan
médical conduit la personnes soumises à
un stress extrême a occulté pendant une
période variable le souvenir des faits
subis
la mémoire est en quelque sorte stockés
dans le corps de la victime qui présente
alors un risque plus important de
développer certaines pathologies et ce
n'est malheureusement que plusieurs
années plus tard à l'occasion d'une
prise en charge
psychothérapeutique que la victime peut
prendre conscience des violences subies
de façon souvent brutales et parfois
très douloureuse
lors de mes auditions le professeur gl
psychiatre et ancien responsable de
l'unité de psycho trauma logis promat
paulo j de l'hôpital tenon a tenu à
attirer l'attention sur le fait que
cette conscientisation des faits subis
dans l'enfance pouvait intervenir
tardivement et bien souvent aux
alentours de 40 ans et c'est vrai que
après 40 ans en est au delà du délai de
prescription tel qu'il est prévu
aujourd'hui
c'est aujourd'hui devant cette
problématique que nous sommes
alors je crois que nous partageons avec
les auteurs le même constat
maintenant qu'en est il des solutions
proposées
la ppl qui est soumise à notre haute
assemblée soulève des difficultés
juridiques
puisque nos collègues sénatrice nous
propose de modifier le délai de
prescription des viols agressions
sexuelles en prévoyant que ce délai ne
commence à courir qu'à partir du jour où
l'infraction apparaît à la victime dans
des conditions ne permettant d'exercer
l'action publique
ce faisant les auteurs de la proposition
de loi propose d'instaurer un parallèle
entre le régime de prescription pour les
viols et agressions sexuelles et celui
mis en place dans la jurisprudence de la
cour de cassation concernant les
infractions aux occultes ou dissimulé et
cette proposition présente de grande
fragilité sur le plan juridique
tout d'abord cette assimilation
est inadaptée dans la mesure où ce droit
de prescription en matière pénale cas
rétabli progressivement la cour de
cassation et ciblées sur certaines
infractions économiques et financières
où l'auteur
d'abus de bien social
effectué une escroquerie en la
dissimulant bien sûr et donc la victime
ne veut pas être au courant qu'il ya eu
escroquerie et c'est pourquoi le délai 3
en cours à partir du moment où
l'escroquerie est révélé d'ailleurs la
jurisprudence de la cour de cassation
est extrêmement fine et si il y a eu des
éléments permettant de démontrer
l'escroquerie dans des livres de comptes
c'est à partir du moment de la
publication des livres que le délai
court et donc on voit que tout le
travail mené par la cour de cassation a
vraiment été ciblés sur ces infractions
économiques et financières et à ce jour
la cour de cassation a refusé d'en
étendre le bénéfice à de nouvelles
branches du droit pénal notamment
d'ailleurs dans un arrêt récent du 18
décembre dernier portant sur la
confirmation d'une ordonnance du juge
d'instruction refusant d'informer pour
cause de prescription
une plainte avec conscient de partie
civile du chef de viol sur mineur de 15
ans par personne ayant autorité
et
comme d'ailleurs l'avocat général la
développer dans ses conclusions la
chambre criminelle n'a recours à cette
notion que dans des affaires où l'auteur
à dissimuler les faits pour en assurer
la clandestinité et dans le cas de viol
on est dans une situation qui est bien
sûr différente
lorsqu'on est dans la situation d'
amnésie il s'agit là de fait qui demeure
ignoré en raison d'un processus
psychiques propre à la victime et c'est
là toute la nuance est toute la
difficulté qui est ensuite engendré en
outre comme l'a souligné le doyen de la
chambre criminelle lors de son audition
par votre rapporteur cette jurisprudence
repose toujours sur des éléments
objectifs comme la date de publication
des comptes de l'entreprise
alors que le souvenir d'événements
traumatisants à la suite d'une amnésie
traumatique ou dissociatifs repousse
repropose pardon nécessairement sur des
éléments subjectifs liés au psychisme de
la victime et on voit bien toute la
difficulté puisque avec des délais
précis au protège aussi quelque part les
victimes qui savent quel est le délai
alors que si tout part d'un élément qui
n'est pas objectif mais qui est
subjectif on phrase i en fragilise
fortement les procédures engagées et on
peut même aboutir à une situation où les
victimes seraient de fait perdante
puisque même par rapport à la situation
actuelle
c'est 18 plus 20 ans soit 38 ans mais si
la victime décide de porter plainte dans
ce délai est que la partie adverse
démontre qu'en fait il n'y a pas eu
amnésie traumatique ou que
faits se sont révélés bien avant et donc
avant le délai de dix ans on est dans
une situation où on lâche en fait la
propre l'ombre et on crée des conditions
où aujourd'hui nous avons une situation
claire et précise et nous aurions demain
des situations où les victimes seraient
lésées et ne pourraient plus porter
plainte parce qu' il faudrait apporter
la preuve de l'amnésie traumatique et du
fait que la fin de la musique dramatique
était bien dans le délai qui était prévu
donc tout ça fait que bien évidemment
cette proposition soulève de nombreuses
questions juridiques et que les
magistrats sont
fortement réticents à l'intégrer dans ce
processus mais au-delà de ces
fragilités que j'ai soulevé il ya
également dans la proposition de la ppl
de sérieux risques d'inconscient alité
en effet il ya tout d'abord un risque au
regard du principe de légalité des
délits et des peines ce principe impose
la nécessité pour le législateur de
définir des infractions en termes
suffisamment clairs et précis pour
exclure l'arbitraire
de ce point de vue en faisant dépendre
le champ de poursuite de l'évolution du
psychisme de la victime qui relève de
facteurs personnels
le dispositif
proposé dans le texte introduirait une
incertitude sur le point de départ du
délai de prescription qui pourrait
ensuite être valablement contester
devant le conseil national et bien
évidemment des auteurs accusé
utiliserait la procédure de la qpc et on
voit ce qui pourrait advenir
s'il était suivi par le conseil national
il existe également un risque importante
au regard du principe d'égalité
ce principe commandes au législateur de
traiter les auteurs d'une mare actions
dans des conditions similaires or en
faisant reposer le point de départ du
délai de prescription sur l'évolution du
psychisme de la victime
la preuve mission de loi de m dini en
l'état aboutir et dans certains cas à
une impression après ce crime est dit
est de facto des faits commis tandis que
dans d'autres cas
la conscientisation précoce par la
victime des faits subis ferait que le
délai serait lui beaucoup plus courts et
donc il y aurait des traitements
différenciés
donc voilà nous avons
une situation
qui est difficile
délicate avec un constat partagé mais
une solution juridique qui n'est pas
satisfaisante et d'ailleurs madame dean
il a bien compris puisqu'elle propose un
amendement à sa propre proposition pour
en fait faire partir le délai du moment
où la personne porte plainte
on voit bien que là on aboutit de fait à
ce que les viols soient imprescriptible
puisque tout dépend du moment où la
plainte est déposée et en france il n'y
a que les crimes contre l'humanité qui
soit imprescriptibles c'est d'ailleurs
le cas dans pratiquement tous les pays
et en seul pays récemment a fait du
crime de viol
quelque chose d'un prescriptibles c'est
la suisse et des débats que nous avons
eus en commission il ressort clairement
que
aucun commissaire de la commission des
lois souhaite aller jusqu'à 7
imprescriptibilité qui mettrait donc le
viol au même niveau que le crime contre
l'humanité il y a la volonté de la part
des membres de la commission de
conserver une échelle dans les
prescriptions et de faire en sorte que
les crimes contre l'humanité soient
vraiment à part avec cette
imprescriptibilité
c'est d'ailleurs
du fait de toutes ces
faiblesses juridiques que la commission
des lois mercredi dernier a émis un avis
défavorable concernant cette proposition
de loi en l'état
jeudi en l'état parce que
vous le verrez par la suite j'ai proposé
des amendements pour allonger le délai
de prescription et ses amendements ont
obtenu un avis favorable
ce matin de la commission
je souhaitais également insisté sur le
fait que la commission des lois du sénat
cela a été rappelé également s'est
prononcée de manière constante
pour qu'il y ait une révision d'ensemble
de ces délais de prescription il ya un
rapport qui date de 2007
suite à une mission d'information
conduite par nos collègues y est ortelli
et young qui a appelé à veiller à la
cohérence du droit de la prescription en
évitant des réformes partielles et en
privilégiant une refonte d'ensemble
et elle a également considéré que toute
modification
devait préserver ce lien entre la
gravité de l'infraction et la durée du
délai de prescription est comme gelée
dit la commission des lois s'est
prononcé de façon constante contre toute
extension du régime d'imprescriptibilité
limité aujourd'hui aux seuls crimes
contre l'humanité
cependant à l'heure actuelle
l'existence de délai fortement
dérogatoire au droit commun s'agissant
des viols et agressions commises sur les
mineurs
marc déjà la sévérité du législateur
mais également le fait que l'on peut
déroger à ce principe sur des cas
particuliers
et la fin de tenir compte du constat
partagé afin d'aller dans le sens des
auteurs mais en restant dans un cadre
juridique abordés je proposerai donc
dont le débat des amendements pour
porter le délai de prescription de viol
de 20 ans à 30 ans donc après la
majorité de la victime ce qui fait donc
jusqu'à quart huit ans parce que c'est
vrai que lorsqu'on entend les victimes
les médecins on voit bien que ce délai
supplémentaire ne sera pas de trop pour
permettre à des personnes après une
amnésie pro stomatique de continuer à
engager des poursuites et à la fois à
empêcher le prédateur d'agir mais
également à se reconstruire
une telle évolution aurait l avantage
d'une cohérence avec le régime de
prescription
spécial applicable à certaines
infractions puisque le délai de 30 ans
est prévue en droit français pour les
crimes de terrorisme ou le trafic de
stupéfiants et elle permettrait de mieux
répondre aux difficultés rencontrées par
les victimes puisque souvent les
traumatismes se révèle au delà de 40 ans
alors c'est vrai qu'il y aura toujours
un effet de seuil mais c'est le problème
avec les délais il ya toujours un effet
de seuil on voit depuis dix ans que
souvent les faits se révèlent autour de
40 ans je considère qu'en portant le
délai de prescription de fêtes de 38 ans
à 48 ans on permettra de toucher
beaucoup plus de victimes je crois que
c'est un progrès et un qui permettra de
répondre en grande partie aux attentes
porté par les auteurs de ce texte de loi
est donc
en accord bien sûr avec madame digne à
qui j'en ai parlé je ferai à ces
propositions nous avons pas fait la
semaine dernière pour permettre au texte
d'arriver en science telle que l'avait
voulu l'auteur ce qui est bien normal
même si con sionnel mans
la commission de loi aurait pu le
modifier mais je crois qu'il fallait que
l'intégralité du débat lieu que les
propositions soient sur la table que le
constat soit partagée et qu'ensuite à
partir de ce constat on puisse trouver
la meilleure solution juridique une
solution qui soit adaptée qui
corresponde à ce qu'attendent les
victimes mais qui doit également
correspondre aussi à ce que peut faire
la justice et à son fonctionnement tout
en respectant la constitution c'est
pourquoi je soumettrai dans le débat ces
deux amendements qui ont recueilli un
avis favorable de la commission des lois
ce matin en l'état donc la commission
des lois est défavorable mais après
débat
si les amendements sont adoptés bien
évidemment la position sera de soutenir
cette proposition de loi ainsi amendé
mes chers collègues je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur la parole est
maintenant à madame la ministre laurence
rossignol secrétaire d'état chargée de
la famille des personnes âgées et de
l'autonomie
monsieur le président monsieur président
de la commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur
madame la sénatrice muguette dini
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
examinons aujourd'hui une proposition de
loi qui a pour objet de reporter le
point de départ du délai de prescription
des agressions sexuelles au jour où je
cite l'infraction apparaît à la victime
dans des conditions permettant
l'exercice de l'action publique ainsi ce
texte s'inspire du mécanisme de
prescription appliquées aux infractions
prédestine tels que l'abus de biens
sociaux ou l'abus de confiance l'exposé
des motifs de la proposition doit révèle
que ces agressions sexuelles en raison
de la nature du traumatisme qu'elles
entraînent et de la situation de
vulnérabilité particulière de la victime
peuvent faire l'objet d'une prise de
conscience ou d'une révélation tardive
et vous l'avez madame dini fort bien
illustré tout à l'heure dans vos propos
ce principe est louable dès lors qu'il a
pour objet de mieux protéger des
victimes d'agressions sexuelles et
surtout de mieux faire valoir leurs
droits la question évoquée à travers ce
texte est une question extrêmement
importante et qui fait quoi des
situations très douloureuses pour ces
victimes de violences sexuelles la
douleur est en effet imprescriptible
cependant votre texte aux plusieurs
difficultés sur le plan technique mais
surtout soulève une réelle question de
constitutionnalité qui conduit le
gouvernement à donner à cette étape un
avis défavorable au texte tel qu'il est
examiné à cet instant les greens article
3 insère un nouvel article 8 1 dans le
code de procédure pénale qui prévoit que
les délais de prescription de l'action
publique ne commence à courir qu'à
partir du jour où l'infraction apparaît
à la victime dans des conditions lui
permettant d'exercer l'action publique
par coordination avec l'article 3 les
articles 1 et 2 supprime au sein des
articles 7 et 8 du code de procédure
pénale la mention prévoyant que les
délais de prescription pour que les
infractions susvisé ne commence à courir
qu'à compter de la majorité de la
victime
les infractions visées par le report du
point de départ du délai de prescription
de l'action publique concerne tant les
mineurs que les majeures jusqu'à présent
le mécanisme de prescription appliquées
pour les infractions occultes ou
clandestine contre les personnes ne
concerne que des faits dont la victime
ne peut pas avoir connaissance karl
agissements frauduleux a été dissimulée
de sorte que le point de départ de la
prescription ne peut qu'être au moment
où ces agissements apparaissent si la
victime peut ne pas avoir connaissance
immédiatement d'un abus de biens sociaux
ou d'un abus de confiance qui lèsent
qu'il à l'aise cela semble en revanche
difficilement transposable aux violences
ayant entraîné une mutilation ou une
infirmité permanente ou une incapacité
temporaire de travail de plus de huit
jours par exemple viser dans la
proposition de loi les mécanismes de
prescription actuellement en vigueur
vise à protéger les victimes les plus
vulnérables
s'agissant des infractions concernant
les mineurs le législateur a d'ores et
déjà adopté des règles dérogatoires à la
prescription est en effet apparu
nécessaire de permettre aux victimes
mineures d'acquérir la maturité et la
force suffisante pour déposer une
plainte et dénoncer des faits indicible
qui peuvent concerner un père un oncle
un proche depuis 1985 le délai de
prescription est ainsi ouvert à nouveau
à compter de la majorité de la victime
lorsque le crime ou le délit a été
commis par un ascendant ou une personne
ayant autorité sur le mineur puis la loi
du 17 juin 1998 défendu ici par
elisabeth guigou a supprimé la condition
d'ascendance ou d'autorité de l'auteur
sur la victime mineure comme critère de
report du délai désormais le délai de
prescription ne commence à courir qu'à
compter de la majorité de la victime
mineure pour tous les crimes ainsi que
les délits visés ci dessous en 2004 le
législateur a rallongé les délais de
prescription pour permettre à la victime
de déposer plainte dans un délai de
vingt ans à compter de sa majorité soit
jusqu'à 38 ans pour les faits de nature
criminelle et correctionnelle aggravés
commis sur un mineur ces dérogations aux
règles de prescription ont été
introduites dans l'objectif de mieux
permettre un mineurs devenus majeurs de
faire valoir ses droits notamment
lorsque l'auteur des faits est un départ
ont un proche si cet objectif répondre à
la fragilité avérée de l'enfant victime
il n'en demeure pas moins que la
procédure engagée par fois plus de
trente ans après les faits et complexe
longue difficile compte tenu de la
déperdition des preuves et des
difficultés à obtenir des témoignages
notamment lorsque les faits ont eu lieu
dans la cellule familiale
assimiler totalement sur le plan de la
prescription est victime majeure à des
victimes mineures ne va pas de soi car
ce serait une forme nette augmentation
de celle ci la proposition faite dans ce
texte pourrait constituer aussi un
retour en arrière car en abrogeant les
dispositions du code de procédure pénale
qui reporte le point de départ du délai
de prescription à la majorité les magies
ce texte conduirait les magistrats a
contrario à s'interroger pour toutes les
victimes mineures sur leur degré de
conscience de l'infraction au moment des
faits ce qui n'est pas non plus
satisfaisant et pose un problème de
principe revenant sur la protection qui
leur a été accordé le point de départ du
délai de prescription ne sera en effet
plus reporter systématiquement pour
certaines victimes mineures notamment
celles proches de la majorité 16 ou 17
ans pour lesquels l'infraction sera
apparu dans des conditions permettant
l'exercice de l'action publique
cet effet secondaire qui pourrait être
pervers de la proposition doit
constituer un retour en arrière du
législateur quant à la protection des
mini des mineurs victimes d'infractions
sexuelles et je sais que ce n'est pas ce
que vous recherchez madame dini la
promotion pose aussi un problème
constitutionnel
mais surtout au delà de ces aspects
techniques est néanmoins important et
non négligeable le report du point de
départ du délai de prescription et le
caractère totalement indéterminé du
point de départ laissé à la seule
appréciation de la victime poserait un
évident problème de conformité à la
constitution
en effet laissé à la seule appréciation
de la victime le point de départ du
délai de prescription aurait pour
conséquence de créer des différences
entre les mises en cause alors même que
la situation est identique même
circonstance de commission de
l'infraction même date des faits bien
plus cela créera également des
distinctions entre deux victimes place
la même situation l'une se verrait
opposé la prescription tandis que
l'autre verrait sa pince propre sa
plainte avant c'est simplement parce
qu'elle avancerait pour des raisons
éminemment subjective n'avoir pas été en
état en état de prendre conscience du
caractère infractionnel infractionnelle
de ce qu'elle aurait subi un tel
dispositif porterait atteinte à trois
exigences constitutionnelles première
exigence l'atteinte au principe de
l'égalité
d'accessibilité et d'intelligibilité des
peines la principe de la légalité oblige
législateur a fixé lui-même le champ
d'application de la loi pénale et
définir les crimes et délits en termes
suffisamment clairs et précis ils se
rattachent à l'objectif de valeur
constitutionnelle
d'accessibilité et d'intelligibilité de
la loi fondée sur les articles 4 5 6 et
16 déclaration des droits de l'homme or
en l'espèce on ne peut à l'évidence
considérée comme claire et précise un
report du point de départ du délai de
prescription des agressions sexuelles au
jour où l'infraction apparaît à la
victime dans des conditions suffisantes
permettant d'exercer l'action publique
ce point de départ est totalement
indéterminé puisqu'il résulte de
considérations subjectives c'est à dire
la perception de la victime de
l'agression
il porte en est également atteinte au
principe d'égalité devant la loi et
devant la justice selon la perception de
la victime une même infraction pourrait
être prescrite dans une affaire est pas
dans une autre les personnes mises en
cause pour des infractions exactement
identique serait donc traitée
différemment certaines pourraient être
poursuivis et condamnés d'autres
échappent d'autres échapperait à la
répression grâce à la prescription ce
qui serait contraire au principe
d'égalité or le conseil constitutionnel
même en présence de certaines
différences objectives justifié entre du
situation de fait ce qui n'est pas
forcément le cas ici est
particulièrement rigoureux notamment
s'agissant de la question du point de
départ de la prescription et il n'hésite
pas à censurer des inégalités
disproportionné de traitement enfin il
portera aussi atteinte au principe de
nécessité et de proportionnalité
le texte permettrait par exemple dans le
cas d'une mineure abusée à l'âge de 8
ans par son frère de 12 ans si la
victime ne se souvient des faits alors
qu'elle a atteint 60 ans et dépose
peintre ensuite ce qu'elle peut alors
faire dans un délai de 10 ans à compter
du moment où les faits ont été révélés
que des poursuites engagées contre
l'auteur présumé près de soixante dix
ans après la commission des faits
dénoncés outre les difficultés de preuve
qui en résulteraient de telles
poursuites par extraits manifestement
disproportionnée et non nécessaire je
mesure la souffrance immense
incommensurable des victimes
d'infraction sexuelle atteinte dans leur
chair dans leur corps et dans leur âme
comme le dit très justement l'exposé des
motifs cependant vous le voyez il est
particulièrement délicat de toucher à
l'économie générale droit de la
prescription qui est un droit complexe
essentiellement jurisprudentielle est
ancien à la faveur d'un texte ne portant
que sur un seul domaine du droit pénal
en outre les poursuites engagées de très
nombreuses années après les faits
pourraient être affectés du fait du
décès du dépérissement des preuves
l'archère la recherche d'une aléatoire
réparation judiciaire ne peut pour les
victimes se substituer à la réparation
médicale l'accompagnement et la prise en
charge rendre justice à la victime est
un des fondements de sa reconstruction
dès lors que cette quête inaboutie n'en
deviendrait pas un obstacle je vous
remercie madame la sénatrice muguette
dini à la fois de votre travail et de la
visibilité que vous avez donné un
domaine du droit qui est entachée du
secret secret de l'enfance secrets de
famille secret de l'inconscient et je
souhaite vivement que grâce au travail
fait par monsieur le rapporteur par la
commission des lois par vous même et cet
après midi par le sénat nous puissions
trouver ensemble la voie qui permette de
répondre aux très juste devoir de mieux
protéger les victimes sans pour autant
porter atteinte au principe de la
proportionnalité des pénates je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre dans la
mesure le président sueur demande à
paroles est là merci monsieur le
président je voulais eux madame la
ministre mes chers collègues revenir sur
le point de procédure qui a été
excellemment évoquée par philippe kalt
en bacs en effet notre commission a
souhaité répondre aux désirs de madame
dini
de voir le texte
arrivé en séance
dans la forme même où elle l'a présenté
je comprends tout à fait ce souhait
e et il apparaît que les groupes
politiques peuvent tout à fait être
attaché à ce que le texte qu'il dépose
arrive en séance publique dans la forme
où ils ont déposé
toutefois je me dois de dire ici
que ce souhait pour légitime et
compréhensible qu'il soit peut tout à
fait entrer en contradiction avec un
principe auquel nous sommes tous très
attachés qu'ils aient le droit
d'amendement et le droit imprescriptible
pour tout sénateur a présenté à toutes
les étapes de la procédure les
amendements qu'ils jugent devoir
proposer
eux la difficulté tient sans doute me
semble-t-il au fait que ces textes sont
inscrits dans des temps réservé et que
par conséquent le temps étant restreint
il est évident d'ailleurs que si
quelqu'un qui est opposée à un texte use
surabondamment du droit imprescriptible
d'amender ce texte il peut faire en
sorte en multipliant les amendements que
le texte ne soit jamais soumis au vote
alors c'est une vraie question que je
veux énoncées ici j'ai quelques idées
sur la réponse possible la réponse
possible j'en ai fait part au président
du sénat qui a instauré une concertation
ce serait tout simplement qu'il y ait
plus de temps dans l'ordre du jour
parlementaire pour les propositions de
loi il ya aujourd'hui deux semaines pour
les projets de loi une semaine pour les
propositions de loi et une semaine pour
le contrôle du gouvernement je ne suis
pas sûr que tous les jours et toutes les
nuits de cette semaine soit utilement
eux utilisés soit utilement affectés aux
contrôles à des activités de contrôle du
parlement le contrôle on le sait passe
davantage par les commission denquête
les questions que nous pouvons poser et
caetera et je crois que si par exemple
ont donné 20 jours au projet de loi et
dix jours opposent proposition de loi on
pourrait régler cette question qui tient
simplement autant limiter eux que dont
nous pouvons disposer mais vous savez
bien mes chers collègues pour changer
cela il faudrait changer la constitution
c'est c'est une lourde contrainte je
tenais toutefois à exposer ce problème
nous avons tenu compte du souhait de
madame dit nicole bouteau non compte du
souhait d'un certain nombre de collègues
de tous les groupes mais nous devons
être aussi attentif en tant que
parlementaire à ce droit d'amendement
qui est un droit tout à fait essentiel
pour chacune et chacun d'entre vous
merci cher président par la suite de la
discussion générale la parole et art
notre collègue esther benbassa pour le
groupe écologiste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues nous examinons
aujourd'hui en première lecture la
proposition de loi de nos collègues
muguette dini chantal jouanno visant à
modifier le délai de prescription de
l'action publique des agressions
sexuelles ces quelques mots de
présentation suffisent pour entrevoir la
difficulté du sujet qui nous est soumis
nous parlons ici des victimes féminines
et masculines d'agression sexuelle de
viol infractions dont l'extrême gravité
est aujourd'hui unanimement reconnue et
dont le législateur comme l'ensemble de
la société doit s'assurer qu'elles
soient lourdement sanctionnés
je veux en préambule assurer les
collègues auteurs de ce texte de mon
amitié et salué le courage de cette
saisie d'un sujet aussi sensible que
douloureux je sais la générosité qui les
anime et qui a présidé à l'élaboration
de cette proposition de loi mais je veux
dire aussi que notre rôle de législateur
et de faire le droit de l'améliorer si
besoin en gardant toujours à l'esprit
les principes fondamentaux qui sont à la
base de notre société
selon le droit actuel en matière de
prescription des infractions sexuelles
il faut différencier selon que la
victime est majeure ou mineure au moment
des faits si la victime est majeur le
délai de prescription comme vous le
savez de 10 ans à compter de la date des
faits pour le viol et de trois ans pour
les autres infractions sexuelles et cela
en conformité avec les délais généraux
de prescription de l'action publique en
matière pénale dix ans pour les crimes
trois ans pour les déliés un an pour les
contraventions
si la victime est mineure les délais ont
été allongés bien sûr tenant justement
compte de la grande ville habilités des
victimes et de l'extrême difficulté pour
les plus jeunes de parler de l'indicible
20 sur 20 ans après la majorité pour les
infractions les plus graves dont viols
attouchements sexuels sur mineur de 15
ans attouchements commis par un
ascendant une personne ayant autorité ou
par plusieurs personnes concernant le
point de départ du délai il s'agit ici
aussi d'un presse d'un principe
fondateur de la procédure pénale il
prend effet le lendemain du jour de la
réalisation de l'infraction le texte que
nous examinons propose de reporter le
point de départ de délais de plex
prescription au jour je cite où
l'infraction apparaît à la victime dans
des conditions permettant l'exercice de
l'action publique il est établi que ces
agressions peuvent faire l'objet d'une
prise de conscience ou d'une révélation
tardive et je cite en raison de leur
nature du traumatisme qu'elles
entraînent et de la situation de
vulnérabilité particulière dans laquelle
elle place la victime fin de citation
elles ont en outre un énorme pouvoir de
sidération et de colonisation du
psychisme des victimes un parallèle dès
lors établi avec le régime des
infractions dissimulait dont le délai de
postes de prescription court à compter
du jour où l'infraction est révélée dans
des conditions permettant l'action
publique
si dans le cas des infractions dissimulé
c'est un fait objectif qui permettent de
révéler l'infraction dans le dispositif
qui nous est proposé ici c'est un
élément tout à fait subjective je cite
l'apparition de la de l'infraction à la
victime qui constituerait le point de
départ du délai de prescription
dans le contexte actuel actuelle
d'efflorescences de discours victimaire
de toute nature
et de valorisation de la condition de
victimes un tel risque ne semble pas
devoir être plus la complexité des
processus psychologique en jeu leur
ténuité et leur habilité sur la longue
durée invite au contraire à la plus
grande prudence aux groupes écologistes
nous nous opposons de longue date à
l'instauration d'un droit toujours plus
d'exceptions et ce en quelques domaines
que ce soit si la présente proposition
de loi était adopté
cela reviendra enfin à rendre les
agressions sexuelles imprescriptible et
donc à les placer au même rang que les
crimes contre l'humanité ce qui pose un
réel problème éthique mais m6 nul le
contexte ne conteste le respect et
l'empathie dû à la personne qui a subi
des violences sexuelles et dont le
souvenir s'est perdu dans le traumatisme
un traumatisme vécu sur le moment le
meurtre quant à lui continuerait à se
prescrire toujours au bout de dix ans ce
qui pour le coup ne sent pas vraiment
raisonnable par conséquent en l'état ce
texte appellera de notre part une
abstention je vous en remercie merci
chers collègues dans la suite de la
discussion madame joëlle garriaud-maylam
a maintenant la parole pour le groupe
ump
je
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues combien de femmes et d'hommes
ont ils regretté de n'avoir eu la force
de dénoncer leurs agresseurs devant la
justice avant que le délai de
prescription ne les en empêche
certains ont mis des années à réaliser
leurs drames parfois occultée dans
l'enfance cette amnésie paralysant la
parole seront un jour pour une raison
inexplicable bien souvent ces souvenirs
ou plutôt ses cauchemars leur reviennent
brusquement mémoire et viennent les
hanter mais il est trop tard à l'automne
2013 le cas de cécile t avait ému la
france entière cette victime de viol
présumée n'était sortie de l'amnésie
dans laquelle elle s'était enfermée
après 32 ans de thérapie son cas avait
tellement fait débat que la cour de
cassation avait été sollicité mais la
plus haute instance judiciaire avait
refusé de repousser le délai de
prescription en matière de crimes
sexuels
je souhaiterais faire un bref rappel de
ce que sont les fondements de la
prescription dans notre état de droit
avant 1989 l'article 7 du code de
procédure pénale se contenter de fixer
des dizaines est révolu la prescription
de l'action publique en matière de crime
le point de départ de ce délai dont le
jour où le crime avait été commis
l'article 8 quant à lui se contenter
pour sa part de fixer à 3 n est le délai
de prescription en matière de délits et
renvoyer à l'article 7 pour les
distinctions spécifier la loi du 10
juillet 1989 relative à la prévention
des mauvais traitements à l'égard des
mineurs et la protection de l'enfance
est venu a ajouté un alinéa à l'article
7 précisant que le point de départ du
délai était reportée à la majorité de la
victime dans le cas où celle ci aurait
été mineure au moment des faits et où le
crime aurait été commis par un ascendant
ou par une personne ayant autorité sur
elle
le report du point de départ du délai de
prescription de l'action public a été
généralisée à l'ensemble des crimes
commis contre les mineurs plus seulement
à ceux commis par ascendant ou personne
ayant autorité et étendue également de
plus nombreux délits commis contre des
mineurs désormais expressément visés le
délai de prescription a en outre été
allongée à 10 ans pour certains délits
lorsque la victime est mineure notamment
les agressions sexuelles sur mineur de
15 ans par ascendant
la justification principale du principe
même de la prescription tient au
dépérissement des preuves et au risque
d'erreur judiciaire qui en résulte dans
un domaine où les éléments physiques
blessure traces biologiques ou autres
s'altèrent rapidement il est souvent
particulièrement difficile de rapporter
la preuve de l'infraction au moyen des
techniques modernes d'investigation
comparaisons adn relevés de traces
rayonnement lumineux
révélations de taches de sang etc
plusieurs années après les faits si des
relevés d'indicés n'ont pu être
effectuées immédiatement
face aux dénégations courante des
personnes suspectées la grande majorité
des enquêtes repousse donc sur
l'évaluation de la crédibilité des dires
de la victime par recoupements avec des
constatations matérielles des
témoignages ou des éléments indirects or
ceux-ci dépérissent ou deviennent très
imprécis avec le temps tu vois une vue
strictement du droit il est donc
impératif que les règles soient claires
et connues le délai de prescription un
caractère d'ordre public il est de
nature à éviter de plus grand désordre
encore que ceux qui ont été initialement
causés par la commission d'une
infraction
aujourd'hui le délai de prescription de
l'action publique de 10 ans pour les
crimes c'est le cas pour le viol il est
ramené à 3 ans pour les délits dont font
partie les agressions sexuelles dont le
sujet nous concerne particulièrement
aujourd'hui
enfin les contraventions sont soumises
un délai de prescription d'un nom
cette répartition connaît des
dérogations notamment en matière
d'infractions sexuelles commises sur des
mineures comme je l'évoquais
précédemment mais cette exception est
liée à l'âge de la victime il ne s'agit
en aucun cas de contester l'importance
du traumatisme subi par les victimes
majeures mais il est fondamental de
comprendre que l'allongement du délai
prévu pour les mineurs doit permettre à
ceux-ci de dénoncer les faits lorsqu'ils
atteignent l'âge adulte et acquiert la
maturité nécessaire pour le faire
vous proposez aujourd'hui chars
collègues cher muguette dini de modifier
non pas le délai de prescription en tant
que tel mais le point de départ de ce
délai c'est à dire de donner le temps
nécessaire à la dénonciation des faits
comme vous l'avez si bien exprimé et
avec une certaine émotion que nous
comprenons si bien dans l'exposé des
motifs de votre ppl je me rappelle d'une
discussion que nous avions eu en 2012
sur une proposition de loi que vous
aviez déjà déposé et qui celle-ci crée
une nouvelle dérogation en assimilant
l'agression sexuelle viol et en alignant
le délai de prescription de l'action
publique des agressions sexuelles sur
celui des viols
pour légiférer en matière de
prescription car tel est bien le sujet
de fond nous devons veiller comme le
recommandait déjà en 2000 c'est nos
collègues jean jacques hyest eu portelli
richard yong que je tiens à saluer tous
les trois pour leur travail approfondir
lactée dans un rapport d'information
très complet que vous avez d'ailleurs
mentionné sharks collègues nous devons
veiller disait à la cohérence du droit
de la prescription en évitant des
réformes partielles mais aussi à
préserver le lien entre la gravité de
l'infraction et la durée de la
prescription de l'action publique afin
de garantir la lisibilité de la
hiérarchie des valeurs protégé par le
code pénal en évitant de créer de
nouveaux régimes dérogatoires
oui ces actes qualifiés d'agressions
sont sexuelles sont graves même
extrêmement graves qu'ils aient été
causés sur des mineurs ou sur des
majeures les traumatismes physiques et
psychiques sont si profonds qu'ils
entrent en qu'il engendre pardon des
troubles cognitifs
considérable perturbant la révélation de
la vérité nous ne pouvons négliger en
tant que législateur s'est pathologie
médicalement reconnu mais nous ne
pouvons non plus perdre de vue la
cohérence de notre arsenal pénal et en
l'occurrence 9 de notre procédure pénale
nous ne pouvons ainsi souscrire à votre
proposition d'amendement qui vise à
modifier le point de départ du délai de
prescription est de le fixer au jour la
victime porte plainte dit même à la
proposition initiale de ne le faire
courir qu'à partir du jour où
l'infraction apparaît à la victime dans
des conditions lui permettant d'exercer
l'action publique en revanche la
proposition du rapporteur d'allonger de
manière exceptionnelle le délai de
prescription de l'action publique et
selon nous une idée très intéressante et
notre groupe ump la soutiendra
ainsi les victimes de ces cas très
douloureux d'agression sexuelle qui ont
trop longtemps trop souvent était
ignorée méprisée au point de même que
certaines d'entre elles ont été parfois
considéré ou ceux considérés parfois
comme partiellement responsables
trouverez ainsi le temps indispensable
pour dévoiler ses secrets enfouis si
profondément je vous remercie
merci
la parole est maintenant à madame
chantal jouanno pour le groupe plus d uc
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues avant d'entrer dans
le texte même je voudrais juste
vous alerter un petit peu sur l'état de
notre société ne sont pas des
moralisateurs mais c'est nécessaire
d'avoir cette confiance et cette
connaissance pour exercer notre rôle de
responsable politique
j'étais assez choqué quand j'ai fait le
rapport sur l'hyper sexualisation des
enfants des chiffres et de la
déliquescence de notre relation à la
sexualité quand on sait que 82 % des
enfants de 11 à 13 ans ont été
confrontés à des images pornographiques
violente et que l'on sait que 50 à 80%
des agresseurs adultes ont commencé dans
leur adolescence c'est un vrai motif
d'inquiétude on nous avions aussi été
choqué avec mon collègue jean pierre
godefroy sur le sujet de la prostitution
de constater la forme de finalement
d'acceptation de tolérance de notre
société à l'égard des violences que
subissent les personnes prostituées et
aujourd'hui on constate qu' un certain
oubli des principes fondamentaux qui
concerne la sexualité à savoir qu'elle
doit être consenti qu'elle ne s'exerce
pas au sein d'une famille et qu' elle ne
s'exerce pas sur des enfants avant la
puberté alors on peut fermer les yeux
sur ces réalités et nous lamenter sur le
coût pour la société ou essayer d'en
fixer les limites et c'est vrai que
notre droit notre constitution
notre bel ordonnancement juridique la
belle architecture du principe de
prescription ne peuvent pas être pensée
en dehors de la société et en dehors des
hommes et les chiffres me ghedini les a
rappelé tout à l'heure ces chiffres sont
colossaux on parle de 383 mixer dans
votre rapport personnes victimes de
violences sexuelles on parle de 26000
dépôt de plainte dont 6000 viol sur
mineure 6000 viol sur mineure quand je
vois tout ce que l'on dit sur les
accidents de la route là on parle de
6000 viol sur mineur est encore
nuggets à rappeler encore une fois ces
chiffres sont doublement minoré ils sont
minorés parce qu'il n'y a pas d' enquête
justement sur les mineurs ils sont
minorés parce que des petites victimes
n'ont pas toujours conscience elles sont
pas ces crimes sont pas conscientiser
comme tel quand vous avez face à vous un
adulte qui vous expliquent que c'est
peut être votre père ou votre mère qui
vous explique c'est normal c'est pour
votre bien
comment pouvez vous avoir conscience que
c'est un crime comment pouvez vous même
tombé dans ce conflit de loyauté puis la
deuxième difficulté celle que nous
aimons qu'aujourd'hui c'est que face à
ces violences sexuelles qui sont
décrites par les victimes comme une
torture
secret et peut se développer une amnésie
post-traumatique une amnésique et même
nécessaire d'ailleurs à la à la survie
de la victime et une amnésie qui est
reconnue sur le plan médical alors là on
parle de milliers de cas milliers de cas
potentiels alors j'ai été vraiment
choqué de lire dans le rapport de la
commission des lois
que ce serait une loi inspirée par un
fait divers
voire sous la pression de lobbys
sécuritaire
à l'est les vis sécuritaire se trouve là
quand on parle de plusieurs milliers de
cas sont pas des faits divers c'est un
fait de société
donc on doit évoluer parce que nos
connaissances ont évolué parce que cette
réalité et mieux documenter aller mieux
révéler parce qu'effectivement
l'amnésie post traumatique elle peut
être assez désagréable parce qu'elle
peut s'arrêter après la fin du délai de
prescription n'a pas toujours conscience
et connaissance de la loi alors oui le
délai de prescription est nécessaire à
notre société il est nécessaire pour sa
stabilité nécessaire surtout pour le
droit finalement à l'oubli et surtout au
pardon mais pour la victime
quand son amnésie prend fin elle se
retrouve à la case départ elle se
retrouve très exactement dans la peau de
la petite fille ou du petit garçon de
l'époque avec la même peur est donc pour
elle ce travail de reconstruction
depardon ou de recherche de vérité ne
peut commencer qu'à compter de cette
date c'est pour ça que le délai de
prescription tel qu'il est et vous
l'avez très bien connu d'ailleurs
monsieur le rapporteur très bien dit
dans votre rapport ce délai tel qu'il
est est inadaptée il est presque
d'ailleurs une source d'inégalités j'ai
également vu dans vos comptes rendus de
la commission des lois que l'agresseur
pouvait avoir construit un nouvel
équilibre social qu'il ne fallait pas
bouleverser trop longtemps après mais
qui peut croire qu'un adulte qui viole
un enfant qui l'obligent à la fellation
ou à la sodomie est un adulte normal qui
même très longtemps après sans
traitement sans accompagnement pourra
retrouver une vie normale
et qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus
inconcevable d'ailleurs et d' ignoble
que ces actes de torture physique et
morale sur des enfants et qui sont bien
souvent d'ailleurs au sein des familles
alors oui notre texte n'est pas parfait
c'est sûr il plaît pas parfait oui prend
le parti des victimes parce que
justement on l'a peut-être pas assez
pris jusqu'à présent oui des conditions
permettant d'exercer l'action publique
sont peut-être incertaine pour être
légale et encore
l'amnésie post traumatique peut être
médicalement constatée s'intégrer dans
une expertise sous l'autorité judiciaire
et en l'espèce je veux bien prendre de
risques d'inconstitutionnalité
d'ailleurs c'est bizarre mais il ya des
textes sur lesquels le risque
d'inconstitutionnalité ça dérange pas
trop
je lis que ce texte crée une
imprescriptible it et defacto l' enquête
permettra peut-être d'éviter ce risque
un risque qui d'ailleurs n'a pas posé
trop de problèmes pour les abus de biens
sociaux on s'inquiète des difficultés
probatoire
effectivement est-ce que 30 ans après
c'est plus difficile que 20 ans après
qu'est ce que les techniques n'ont pas
évolué dans les deux cas on répond non
c'est pareil je sais que vous auriez
préféré une remise à plat de l'ensemble
du régime de prescription nous aussi
voilà un sujet d'ailleurs qui a été
brillamment étudier dans un rapport du
sénat
en 2007 nous sommes sept ans après il ya
deux ans j'ai déjà entendu qu'on allait
le faire que c'était imminent
donc les promesses sont identiques mais
rien n'a bougé rien n'a bougé
et c'est vrai que dans le rigoureux
édifice de la prescription il ya déjà eu
bien des brèches qui finalement été
accepté j'ai cité l'abus de bien social
mais il ya les trafics de stupéfiants il
ya le terrorisme donc des cas où
finalement les brèches dans l'ordre
juridique semble plus acceptable que
d'autres donc nous serions tous désireux
d'un changement du régime de
prescription mais si on pouvait avoir
confiance dans des délais clairs précis
sincère on pourrait poser même la
question finalement d'imprescriptibilité
d'ailleurs des crimes sur les enfants
mais nous n'avons pas totalement
confiance dans ses promesses donc nous
préférons vous proposer d'agir plutôt
qu'attendre et je veux vraiment
remercier et muguette dini pour sa
constance et son combat et vous
remercier monsieur le rapporteur parce
que je sais que vous n'étiez pas
nécessairement partie en suivant les
mêmes orientations que nous au départ et
finalement vous êtes aussi aujourd'hui
un défenseur de ces propositions en tout
cas vous avez reconnu la véracité des
faits je vous remercie
merci beaucoup à madame chantal jouanno
pour le groupe crc maintenant c'est
madame cécile que kaman qui a la parole
et le micro
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues permettez moi tout
d'abord de saluer le travail réalisé par
entre autres par notre collègue muguette
dini je crois loin de vouloir mener une
politique d'affichage a fait avec
d'autres élus de la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles un combat le texte
qui nous est proposé pose une vraie
question en effet son analyse nous a
conduit à reconnaître les réelles
difficultés d'application du régime de
prescription en matière d'infractions
sexuelles mais en poussant l'analyse un
peu plus loin nous avons aussi constaté
que les difficultés liées à la
prescription en matière pénale dépasse
les cas d'infractions sexuelles comme le
révèle de récentes décisions rendues par
la chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation et appelle de fait à une
réforme plus globale avant de développer
ce point je voudrais tout d'abord
nuancer les arguments qui ont conduit au
rejet de ce texte en commission sur la
question des difficultés probatoire tout
d'abord celles ci sont réels et le
dépérissement des preuves est l'un des
fondements traditionnelle qui justifie
la prescription mais je voudrais réfuté
ici l'argument qui consiste à dire que
le risque de non lieu qui serait
prononcée faute de preuves suffisantes
sera douloureusement ressentie par la
victime car il n'est pas certain qu'un
refus d'instruire pour cause
d'écoulement de temps soit finalement
mieux reçus par cette victime notre
rapporteur a lui même nuancé cet
argument il a soutenu que la diff les
difficultés de preuve ne doivent pas
forcément être un obstacle à
l'instruction d'une affaire car donner
la possibilité à une personne se disant
victime de voir instruire son affaire
peut aussi conduire à délier les paroles
d'autres victimes du même suspects
pourront alors se manifester donc
d'autres agressions éviter
soit la nécessité d'envisager toute
réforme de la prescription de manière
globale il n'est pas absurde de
considérer que la spécificité des
infractions sexuelles par rapport à
d'autres crimes délits peut mériter une
crise on compte particulière de la loi
relative à la prescription comme cela a
pu être le cas pour d'autres infractions
infraction notre collègue vient de le
rappeler en matière de stupéfiants de
terrorisme d'infraction d'affaires qui
ont parfois fait l'objet de réformes
parcellaire en effet si le mutisme des
victimes rend difficile l'élaboration
d'études médecins et victimologue
insiste sur la spécificité des violences
sexuelles par rapport à d'autres créés
ou délit certaines études ont été menées
vous l'avez cité madame la rapporteure
elle souligne notamment une qui souligne
dans une étude menée sur 100 patients 88
femmes et 12 hommes que la
conscientisation agression sexuelle
s'est fait chez 47 % des patients au
delà du délai de prescription est que
dans 90% des cas la possibilité de
parler des survenue qu'après un long
voire très long travail thérapeutique de
réparation sur le parallélisme fait
entre les infractions sexuelles et les
infractions clandestine tout extinction
du sein de ces infractions ne peut être
envisagée avec attention sous peine de
fragiliser le régime juridique déjà
fragiles d infraction clandestine qui
parce qu'il est de sources prétorienne
fait l'objet de nombreuses critiques il
est en effet reproché à cette
jurisprudence qui s'applique surtout des
vies d'affaires cela a été rappelé
d'être finalement contraire au principe
de l'égalité
malgré cette critique dans la pratique
la solution adoptée par l' agence
prudence et cohérente et elle permet
notamment de sanctionner la criminalité
que l'on appelle criminalité des cols
blancs et de poursuivre un type de
criminalité très technique cette théorie
relève d'une idée qui n'est pas faux ce
qui correspond à la philosophie de la
prescription cependant l'absence de
définition législatives a rendu
difficile la détermination un critère
objectif rendant compte des infractions
clandestine si bien que la solution de
report du délai de prescription pour
certains délits que ta part être
arbitraire en ce qu'elle ne concerne
qu'une partie des infractions comme le
souligne en filigrane le texte de nos
collègues madame digne et jouanno
doit-on pour autant considéré que les
agressions sexuelles relèvent de cette
catégorie pour le déterminer le faut
tenter de déterminer finalement quels
critères retiennent les juges pour
retenir ceux qui relèvent de cette
catégorie ou non ce qui ressort la
plupart du temps c'est que le caractère
de clandestinité concerne l'acte
incriminé lui même c'est à dire son
élément derrière cet acte sept éléments
matériels a fait l'objet de manoeuvre de
la part de l'auteur volontairement pour
dissimulé l'infraction on peut
considérer dès lors que les infractions
sexuelles ne relève pas de la catégorie
d infraction clandestine car
l'occultation que les agressions
sexuelles engendre souvent ne se trouve
pas dans l'acte répréhensible lui-même
mais elle dépend cela était très bien
rappelé de la victime la référence à la
clandestinité et particulièrement des
lits d'affaires fait dans l'exposé des
motifs ne peut donc être retenue mais il
est vrai l'idée se conçoit dans
l'absence de définition est relative
engendre des pauvres fusion ces concepts
confusion se trouvent parfois même dans
la loi en effet la loi du 14 mars 2011 a
introduit un article dans le code des
procédures pénales pénale disposant que
pour les personnes vulnérables
le délai ne court qu'à compter du jour
où l'infraction apparaît la victime dans
des conditions permettant l'exercice de
l'action publique pour certains délits
ici la vulnérabilité qui ne se trouvent
pas dans l'élément matériel de
l'infraction mais qui concerne la vie la
victime conditionne bien la
clandestinité au prix d'une certaine
dénaturation de cette dernière de sorte
qu ici les infractions clandestine
tienta l'ignorance dans laquelle se
trouve la victime et le ministère public
quant à leur existence comme je vous
disais de nombreuses affaires révèle les
difficultés des différents régimes de
prescription en matière pénale ces
difficultés des passes mais englobe
aussi les infractions sexuelles il y a
quelques jours une cour d'appel statuant
sur renvoi après cassation a tenu tête à
une autre juridiction dans une affaire
de report du point de départ du délai de
prescription dans une affaire
d'infanticides les juges de la cour
d'appel qui ne doute pas qu'ils seront
censurés une seconde fois appel
implicitement une réforme une réflexion
a déjà été menée sur la été rappelé m
elle se trouve sur nos bureaux depuis le
20 juin 2007 il s'agit du rapport de
notre commission sur la prescription
évoqué par votre rapporteur je vous
propose de nous en saisir afin de
trouver à l'ensemble de cette situation
des solutions pérennes rationnelle et
rassurante en attendant notre groupe
vous l'aurez compris s'abstiendra sur la
proposition de loi tel qu'il est tel
qu'elle est à ce jour rédigé même si
nous en partageons le constat mais
finalement si doutons du dispositif et
de la réponse apportée dans le temps qui
me reste permettez moi d'évoquer les
trois amendements du rapporteur qui
s'ils sont adoptés revienne à un nouveau
texte les agressions crimes sur mineurs
sont des actes graves mais vous savez
que l'augmentation des prescriptions ne
diminuera en rien leur nombre
contrairement à ce qui a pu être entendu
pour cela il faut agir sur la prévention
aider à délier les paroles et de ce côté
le travail est encore possible
n'oublions pas que le viol n'a fait son
entrée dans le code pénal comme 1992 par
ailleurs le temps nécessaire pour
s'émanciper de la cellule familiale qui
est évoqué pour justifier ses
abonnements possibles peut aussi l'être
pour une victime majeure je pense ici
aux mariages forcés qui est un viol en
soi et peut-on justifier qu'une personne
de 17 ans puisse agir pour leurs trente
ans de fête et celle de 18 ans pendant
dix ans enfin l'amnésie traumatique si
elle touche effectivement de façon très
forte les enfants elle touche également
les adultes of in fine et l'argument
évoqué par notre commission ce matin
pour rejeter le texte initial à savoir
modifier un délai de prescription soit
intégré dans une réflexion globale que
là encore être opposés sur les
abonnements qui nous sont soumis et
finalement je pense que plutôt que de
rallonger la question le délai de la
prescription je crois que la question
initiale qui était posée par nos
collègues même si la réponse nous
l'avons dit était peut-être maladroite
étaient réels c'est à dire à partir de
quand ce délai doit courir plutôt que de
rallonger toujours un peu plus raide de
prescription mais nous y reviendrons
dans le cas du débat des abonnements
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue jean claude requier pour le
groupe rds
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président la commission des
lois mais c'est le rapport terme et sa
collègue la modification du délai de
prescription des agressions sexuelles
est désormais un sujet que nous
connaissons bien notre collègue muguette
dini avait déjà déposé une proposition
de loi ce sujet ça avait été rejetée par
le sénat en janvier 2012 une nouvelle
fois les membres du groupe rdse ne
votera pas ce texte à l'état nous
tenions à le dire d'emblée si les
intentions des auteurs de cette
proposition de loi sont louables le
propre boulot prononcera également
contre les modifications à tout va des
prescriptions en matière pénale qui
créent des prescriptions à la carte la
non prescription des crimes contre
l'humanité a fini de transformer sens de
la loi de prescription en une échelle
gravité concurrente à celle des peines
ce qui n'était pas sa fonction première
le législateur n'a cessé d'introduire
des exceptions à la règle quitter celle
du 1 3-10 précision d'un homme pour les
contraventions trois ans pour les délits
et dix membrés crime les années
1960 en vue naître des exceptions à la
règle générale relative au point de
départ du délai de prescription
puis dans les années 90 il est introduit
d'exception règles générales relatives
aux délais de prescription
les infractions sexuelles font tous
l'objet d'un régime dérogatoire on l'a
dit au type de prestations notamment
pour les victimes mineures le point de
départ du délai de prescription de
l'action publique a été reporté la
majorité de la victime qui reste qu'il
s'agisse d'un crime ou d'un délit les
interventions du législateur se sont
ainsi succédé à un rythme soutenu
créée en dhr et le problème
d'application de la loi dans le temps
sans parvenir à résoudre les difficultés
inhérentes aux mécanismes de la
prescription mes chers collègues la
suppression de toute prescription en
matière pénale
peut paraître séduisante à bien des
égards c'est ce vers quoi tendre et in
fine et la proposition de loi de nos
collègues centristes si elle était votée
en se basant sur un critère purement
subjectif celui de la prise de
conscience de la victime pour faire
courir le des principes sion les
agressions sexuelles de vendres est
quasiment impossible
toutefois non seulement cette
suppression de la prescription irait à
l'encontre de l'équilibré aujourd'hui
trouver entre 3 les victimes et procès
équitable mais encore elle aurait
d'innombrables connaissance par
conséquence pratique qui samedi visite
de gérer ça lui substituer d'autres
mécanismes juridiques comment ce cas
rendra justice quand le dépérissement
des preuves empêche toute reconstitution
reconstitution des faits notamment en
matière d'agression sexuelle la jument
est imparable il a été soumis et de
nombreuses fois la prescription par et à
ce titre est un mal nécessaire de la
procédure pénale elle constitue une
limitation posées par les dégustateurs à
tentation de l'expansion 107 de la
réponse pénale la modification des
prescriptions
demande un peu plus de réflexion comme
il atterrit en commission des lois la
prescription en matière pénale
mériterait une véritable remise à plat
sur la base du rapport de nos collègues
yes portelli et young meunier pneus n'y
sommes pas ainsi les difficultés liées à
la prescription en matière d'agression
sexuelle mais nous contestons le
bien-fondé et l'efficacité du dispositif
du texte proposé comment dans ce cas ne
pas laisser les incidents les
infractions sexuelles tombe dans l'oubli
et se banaliser telle est la vraie
question qui se pose la modification des
règles de prescription n'est
manifestement pas une règle une réponse
adaptée à la nature l'agression sexuelle
alors que le sujet était encore tabou
pour les générations précédentes des
études montrent que la reconnaissance
sociale de ces violences contribuer à
une modification du seuil de rejet à
l'égard des agressions sexuelles
toutefois encore aujourd'hui seule une
minorité de ces infractions est porté à
connaissance des autorités probablement
les plus graves une enquête de
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance et des réponses pénales
montre que seuls 11% des femmes et 2 %
des hommes ont porté plainte pour des
infractions à caractère sexuel hors
ménage
esi parce qu'elles sont le fruit de
certains mentalité et de certains
comportements
parfois inspirés institutionnalisée et
normalisé des moyens supplémentaires
doit être mis en oeuvre pour faire
connaître l'endroit où victime elle
incite à porter plainte et leur
permettre d'être mieux prises en charge
par les professionnels du monde
judiciaire ainsi que par les
psychothérapeutes cela passe également
par une sensibilisation du grand public
azur et agression sexuelle
la gestion du métro de lille en avril
dernier démontre combien il est urgent
d'agir pour fui dans le métro puis à une
rue une seule femme a suivi pendant les
32 minutes les assauts de jeu non
alcoolisées avant d'aller eux-mêmes
chercher du secours et ce devant une
dizaine de témoins est impassible
indifférent
c'était un différend cela qu'il faudrait
de désamorcer afin que le taux
d'agressions sexuelles puisse diminuer
c'est aussi cette indifférence qui rend
parfois difficile
une dénonciation de 17
ici le droit à l'oubli mise à jour de la
prescription et moins en cause qu' une
augmentation des réponses pénales wendel
ou trente ans après les faits
d'agression sexuelle
dans ces conditions
les membres du groupe rdse nous pourrons
apporter leur soutien à ce texte
le mode mais qui est pas beau
car il me semble et le constituer une
fausse bonne réponse juridique
il a ces cas là nous ne voterons pas des
versets chers collègues
on attendait du sud d'une météo
meilleure
monsieur jean pierre michel
pour le groupe socialiste
ce président à mme lamia ministre mes
chers collègues
tout d'abord je crois qu'il faut saluer
l'initiative
des signataires de ces propos ils sont
devenus ma maladie ni qui nous permet
cet après-midi de débattre d'un sujet
important horrible celui des crimes
commis sur les mineurs garçons aux
filles par des membres de leur famille
par des proches par des amis de la
famille par des éducateurs par des
prêtres par des ministres du culte
tout ceci nous le connaissons de loin
parce que dans nos permanences
parlementaires nous avons pu entendre
ces victimes qui sont venus se plaindre
très longtemps après qui quelquefois ne
savait plus à qui s'adresser pour
essayer de
non pas de réparer mais de dire ce qui
s'était passé quelques années auparavant
alors pour essayer de répondre à cette à
cette question les auteurs de la
proposition de loi nous nous propose de
rallonger la prescription pour ceux qui
possédaient pour ses crimes et délits il
faut dire d'abord que cette prescription
est déjà exceptionnelle puisqu'elle en
fait elles courent vingt ans après la
majorité c'est à dire qu'on a jusqu'à
l'âge de 38 ans pour
porter plainte et pourquoi déjà fait
exception dans l'échelle des
prescriptions on le sait très bien parce
que
au début ces victimes sont sous
l'emprise
exercée par les auteurs des faits
notamment lorsqu'il s'agit d'éducateurs
proches ou des membres de leur famille
ou de maître d'internât comme on l'a lu
récemment
parce que ces victimes on le sait ont un
sentiment de culpabilité extrêmes
pendant très très longtemps
et que bien souvent également
l'entourage est complice de l'auteur des
faits il les connaît on a tous vu des
des mères
qui couvre les pères incestueux
ne serait ce que parce que il faut que
il rapporte l'argent à la maison et que
ça tourne
et puis parce que la parole de l'enfant
est souvent dénigré n'ai pas entendu et
que
c'est très difficile de d'aller voir les
services depuis la mairie et donc tous
ceux ci constituent des obstacles très
important et donc on a prévu déjà
d'attendre que la victime est atteint
une période de sa vie où sa maturité ça
le changement dans sa vie le fait
qu'elle se soit marié peut-être qu'elles
aient des enfants etc lui permettent de
de dire l'indicible quelques années
auparavant
alors la proposition de loi propose
d'aller encore plus loin
puisqu'elle propose de faire commencer
le délai de prescription à partir du
moment finalement alors on ne sait pas
quelle version prendre où la plainte a
été déposée ou bien où la victime et est
à même de réaliser ce qui s'est passé et
de mettre en
mouvement l'action publique
pourquoi bien pour une raison qui est
médicalement aujourd'hui connus et
reconnus
parce que en plus des handicaps que j'ai
énoncé à l'instant et bien il y en a il
existe il existe ce phénomène d'amnésie
traumatique qui fait que les victimes
enfouies au fond d'elle-même ni ce qui
s'est passé peut-être pour se
reconstruire ou
plus souvent d'ailleurs pour mener une
vie chaotique
quelquefois d'addiction et que
finalement après une analyse une
psychanalyse quelquefois des séances
d'hypnose et bien le fait est horrible
ressurgit tout d'un coup et la victime
et je dirais violet ou atteintes une
seconde fois c'est ce que disent les
psychiatres et les médecins spécialistes
de ces questions et donc
quelquefois il est entendu
ça peut dépasser l'âge de 38 ans qui est
aujourd'hui la limite de la prescription
c'est la raison pour laquelle nos
collègues ont déposé cette proposition
de loi bien sûr ici je pense que toutes
et tous nous partageons le
constat qui a été fait par madame dini
et ses collègues et nous voudrions y
apporter une réponse
mais on l'a dit avant moi la proposition
de loi en l'état n'est pas acceptable
pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que elle tendrait à
l'imprescribilité de l'infraction or
seuls
les crimes contre l'humanité sont
imprescriptibles
et
d'autre part
je passe et puis et puis également parce
que si on retenait la
le ce que madame dini mais notre
proposition de loi seul remède c'est à
dire que c'est la victime qui exercent
l'accent public or l'action publique
passée par la victime mais depuis on a
un peu corrigé cette rédaction plus
important surcroît il faut s'interroger
sur ce qu'est la prescription pourquoi y
at-il en droit pénal
une prescription pour quelles raisons
après tout on pourrait concevoir que
l'on puisse dénoncer les crimes ou des
délits
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie si on a été
victime
parce que il ya un espèce d'équilibré
social
entre le droit à l'oubli qui est la
sécurité je dirais dudu du milieu social
la stabilité
et puis la répression d'une infraction
et le fait de l'image et des victimes et
cet équilibre est bien fêté hier ils se
retrouvent dans les délais de
prescription plus ou moins long
d'abord délai normal de 10 en matière de
crime et puis d'exception qui ont été
ajoutées au fil des ans pour un certain
nombre de crimes et de délits et qui
permettent d'aller plus loin que les dix
ans mais la commission des lois du sénat
s'est penché plusieurs fois
cette question
faut bien dire madame dini que vous
l'avez un peu bouleversé jospin poyet
notre terme puisque dans un rapport
récent le président y est ce monsieur
portelli et monsieur jung avait proposé
de revoir totalement la matière de la
prescription pour l'amérique à remettre
à plat et faire en sorte que cette
prescription soit mieux adapté à
l'échelle des peines car le conseil
constitutionnel demande ça aussi c'est
qu'une des raisons qui peut être ferez
votre rédaction ne serait peut-être pas
ne passerez pas encore c'est que notre
tête si tenté qu'il soit si mais il
pourrait par une qpc plus tard et donc
la commission des lois bien entendu à a
eu du mal à accepter a accepté fait
cette rédaction d'autre part
je vous le dis la comparaison que vous
faites avec les les les lèvres action
occultes ou simulées n'est pas
acceptable en effet il ne s'agit pas du
tout
d'infraction occultes ou dissimuler
comme l'abus de confiance abus de biens
social etc il s'agit d'infractions qui
ont été occultés ou dissimulées par la
victime elle-même parce qu' elle n'a pas
pu s'en ouvrir parce qu'elle n'a pas pu
s'exprimer et parce qu'un beau jour eh
bien ça éclate et ça peut se dire donc
c'est pas du tout je crois il faut cette
comparaison ne n'est pas raison
enfin
l'imprescribilité l'imprescriptibilité
bon n'est pas n'est pas acceptable et
d'autre part je rappelle quand même que
les crimes de guerre se prescrivent que
par 30 ans
or les crimes de guerre ça concernant le
c1 des viols en chaîne des assassinats
des meurtres etc etc
et puis enfin et puis enfin il faut
quand même bien voir que après autant
d'années
qu'elle pourrait être quelle serait
l'issue du procès bien sûr on pourrait
retrouver l'épreuve aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs il ya une une modernisation
dans l'art ancien des preuves avec des
recherches adn et c'est bon d'autre part
les victimes appelé les auteurs à
presser temps là peuvent être décédée
peuvent avoir ces vrais refait leur vie
et on peut ajouter un traumatisme à leur
famille qu'ils ignoraient tout de ce qui
s'est passé ça peut arriver aussi et
puis il ne faut pas non plus donner aux
victimes le le sentiment que après tant
de temps finalement elle réussirait
d'anciennes recherche est en fait qu'est
ce qu'elle recherche le procès pénal
n'est pas fait d'abord pour les victimes
il n'est pas fait d'abord pour réparer
le traumatise qu'elles ont subi il est
fait d'abord pour réprimer sanctionner
une infraction et puis bien entendu pour
dédommager la victime
et
si on le voit dans d'autres domaines
d'ailleurs
quelques fois il ya des procès il ya des
condamnations des victimes sans prise en
compte et en fait elles ne sont pas
satisfaites parce qu'elle voudrait autre
chose et dans ces affaires là on voit
bien ce qu'elles veulent elles veulent
une parole elles veulent une excuse
elles veulent que l'auteur de
l'infraction en face d'elle dans une
enseigne public dise ce qui s'est passé
le regrette et s'excuse et ça c'est
quand même assez rare donc je crois
qu'il faut rester quand même très
prudent sur ce que vous avez proposé
madame mesdames et mesdames messieurs
les auteurs de la proposition de loi
alors à cet instant pour ne pas être
plus long parce que beaucoup de gens
dont été dit je voudrais quand même
dire que dans nos groupes dans mon
groupe on s'est longtemps interrogé on
s'est interrogé en groupe deux fois sur
ce qu'il a de mieux de faire tout le
monde disait oui le constat est clair
nous sommes tous d'accord mais ce qu'on
nous propose n'est pas possible voilà
pour des raisons et peut-être d'autres
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut trouver et
oui ça s'est passé c'est comme ça que ça
s'est passé il faut dire les choses
comme elles sont et donc on n'a pas à
balayer d'un revers de main
et donc comme on le fait quelques fois
que les propos de cendres venant de
l'opposition si madame dini vous êtes là
au centre
et donc et donc je veux remercier le
travail de philippe cattin bac qui a
fait beaucoup d'auditions c'est vrai et
qui finalement nous a proposé alors
certains diront une demi mesure d'autres
diront un progrès le progrès c'est que
on évite les consulte réalité on évite
le fait de dire que l'action publique
seraient portés par la victime elle-même
mais on ajoute 10 ans à la prescription
voilà est en fait cela
fait en sorte que les personnes victimes
de ces attentats death et traumatisent
horrible qu'elles ont subies dans leur
enfance ou dans leur jeunesse ont
jusqu'à l'âge de 48 ans alors bien sûr
des exceptions bien sûr ça peut arriver
la révélation à 50 ans bon mais on met
dix ans de plus et ainsi peut-être qu'on
peut englober un certain nombre de cas
douloureux qui existent aujourd'hui que
vous avez cités madame que vous
connaissez qui n'ont pas pu
faire valoir leur leurs paroles parce
que c'était trop tard mais qui peut-être
avec des dix ans supplémentaires le
pourront donc dans ces conditions bien
entendu le groupe socialiste adoptera
l'amendement ou les amendements parce
que il celui de monsieur kalt un bac et
s'ils sont adoptés par notre assemblée
votera la production des lois que vous
avez présenté je vous remercie
merci beaucoup chers collègues la parole
est maintenant à madame catherine de
roche dernier orateur au nom de l'ump
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
mes chers collègues la forte prévalence
au sein de la société française des
violences sexuelles est immense et
inacceptable parce qu'elle atteigne la
victime dans son intimité les violences
sexuelles diffère des autres types de
violence et justifie la mise en place de
dispositif spécifique de prise en charge
et d'accompagnement des victimes
je rappellerai que l' enquête conjointe
de l'insee de l'observatoire national de
la délinquance et des réponses pénales a
mené une enquête auprès de personnes
âgées de 18 à 75 ans selon les
évaluations réalisées et cela a été 10
383 mille personnes sont victimes de
violences sexuelles en 2010 83 mille
femmes sont victimes de viol ou de
tentative de viol ces chiffres alarmants
démontre à quel point ce type de
violence constituent un véritable fléau
contre lequel nous devons lutter mais
qui plus est mme guay dean il a rapporté
l'ampleur de ce phénomène est largement
sous-estimée d'une part les enquêtes ne
conte pas ne comptabilise pas les
agressions perpétrées sur des mineurs et
l'on sait les ravages de ces agressions
sur les enfants où l'on touche là
souvent à l'inimaginable
d'autre part les déclarations auprès des
autorités les dépôts de plainte ne
représente qu'un faible pourcentage du
nombre réel d'abus en effet une victime
sur 6 de violences conjugales physiques
ou sexuelles déclare avoir porté plainte
une victime sur dix
viol ou tentative de viol portée plein
le nombre de condamnations inscrites au
casier judiciaire
s'établit de 7000 à 8000 en moyenne par
an alors que les faits de violences
sexuelles constatées par la police et la
gendarmerie sont plutôt de l'ordre de 22
mille à 23000
les victimes d'agressions sexuelles
éprouve toujours les plus grandes
difficultés à parler du drame qu'elles
ont vécu les raisons en sont multiples
la peur la honte le déni mais aussi cela
a été dit l'amnésie traumatique qui suit
le choc émotionnel profond le
traumatisme subi peut placer la victime
dans l'impossibilité dénoncé les faits
subis pendant une période qui peut
s'avérer très longue à l'occasion des
assises nationales sur les violences
sexuelles organisé en janvier dernier
par notre collègue muguette dini en
partenariat avec l'association stop
violences sexuelles le docteur violaine
guerra médecin endocrinologue et
gynécologue et présidente de
l'association a bien exposé ce
traumatisme elle a d'ailleurs précisé
que l'amnésie traumatique et ce point
important pouvait être médicalement
constaté un médecin psychiatre formés à
cette problématique est en mesure de
l'établir scientifiquement dans le même
sens dans le cas de la commission
spéciale de lutte contre la prostitution
le docteur muriel salmona nous a
présenté ses travaux sur la mémoire
traumatique
avec les conclusions notamment
d'imagerie médicale qui sont des preuves
scientifiques
il y a plusieurs raisons qui expliquent
que ces violences sont souvent occultés
par les victimes lors du violent la
perte de connaissance n'est pas rare un
viol peut engendrer des mécanismes de
déconnexion du cerveau le viol et me
ghedini l'a rappelé le de plus en plus
souvent réalisés chez des personnes qui
ont été alcoolisée ou drogué qui n'ont
plus le souvenir de ce qui s'est passé
un viol réalisé dans la très jeune
enfance peut faire partie des souvenirs
oubliés et un viol peut n'être pas
conscientiser comme tel le syndrome de
stress post traumatique peut conduire la
victime à trois types de réactions dans
un premier temps la personne peut se
remémorer périodiquement les événements
ou bien peut être victime de cauchemars
ou deux rappels d'image récurrent dans
un second cas la personne fait tout pour
éviter d'être confronté une situation
qui rappelle les événements
traumatisants
dans ce cas la victime ressent sentiment
de culpabilité et l'a conduit au silence
ou au repli sur soi enfin la victime
connaît des difficultés à se concentrer
à mener à terme ses activités ce qui l'a
conduit à des phénomènes d'insomnie
d'instabilité d'irritabilité ou
d'agressivité c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'hyperstimulation et je n'évoque pas
toutes les conséquences physiques
multiples que décrivent les victimes
d'après plusieurs études 42,8 pour cent
des femmes et 33 3% des hommes la
conscience chez les chiffres je viens
donner la conscientisation des
agressions c'est fait après l'âge de 38
ans dans plus de 90% des cas la
possibilité de parler des faits n'est
survenu qu'après un travail
thérapeutique de réparation et au delà
des 38 ans cet âge de conscientisation
tardif a pour conséquence d'empêcher la
victime d'obtenir réparation puisque le
délai de prescription est écoulé les
délais de prescriptions actuelles sont
donc inadapté
partant de ce constat à titre personnel
je soutiens l'esprit de la proposition
de loi déposée par mes collègues des
dignes et chantal jouanno visant à
reporter le point de départ du délai de
la prescription à partir du moment où la
victime en mesure de révéler
l'infraction dont elle a été victime
bien entendu je suis conscient des
obstacles juridiques soulevées par cette
proposition de loi vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le rapporteur transposer aux
agressions sexuelles la jurisprudence
relative aux infractions occultes et
délicat d'autre part et madame la
ministre a également souligné il
existera un risque
d'inconstitutionnalité
sur le plan du principe de légalité et
sur le plan du principe d'égalité mais
chantal jouanno l'a bien dit ce risque
est souvent et souvent fréquent dans nos
textes la question des délais de
prescription voire de
l'imprescriptibilité est un problème
complexe le débat que nous avons cet
après-midi le prouve monsieur le
rapporteur vous allez nous proposer des
amendements qui selon vous permettrait
de sécuriser les dispositions juridiques
de ce texte et qui pourrait peut-être
constituer un premier pas vers une
meilleure législation pour toutes les
personnes victimes de tels drames en
attente d'un texte global sur la
prescription mais je rappellerai que le
temps législatif
avec sa longueur est difficile cas pour
les victimes chaque jour passé est un
jour de lourds eux je vous remercie
pautrat tous
merci
chers collègues la discussion générale
est close la commission n'ayant pas
élaboré de textes nous passons à la
discussion des articles de la
proposition de loi initiale
sur l'article 1er amendement numéro 2
présenté par le rapporteur au nom de la
commission
j'en ai parlé dans mon intervention
il s'agit en partant du constat de
trouver une solution juridique qui comme
l'a dit j'obtiens michel pourra être vu
comme un premier pas même si elle ne va
pas jusqu'où souhaité des auteurs il
s'agit en fait de remplacer dans
l'article 7 du code de procédure pénale
le mot vin par le mot 30 et donc faire
passer le délai de prescription de 20 à
30 ans pour les viols sur mineure donc
les arguments ont dit de venir dans le
débat je crois qu'il faut trouver une
solution et cette solution permettra de
couvrir de nombreux cas dont a fait état
à madame digne et et c'est vrai que les
médecins que j'ai eu l'occasion
d'auditions aimons tous
confirmé que bien souvent
la révélation se faisait à la
quarantaine et avec un délai de trente
ans on passe de 38 à 48 ans ce délai
n'est pas exceptionnel puisqu'il existe
pour les crimes de guerre pour les
crimes de terrorisme depuis les années
et puis également pour les crimes liés
au trafic de stupéfiants et donc
ce ne serait pas quelque chose
d'aberrant et qui ont une rente dans l'
architecture générale de ces délais de
prescription c'est pourquoi je vous
soumets cet amendement qui a été
adopté ce matin par la commission des
lois je voulais juste je profite de
l'occasion qui m'est donnée faire
remarquer que dans mon rapport je n'ai
jamais écrit que la proposition était
le fruit d'un travail de lobbying
d'associations sécuritaire ou le fais
je sais bien voilà moi ce qui m'agace
c'est le rapport que j'ai rédigée
ensuite sont annexés les débats avec les
interventions des sénateurs de la
commission et ça je ne suis pas
responsable voilà c'est chaque
commissaire qui assume ses propos je ne
suis pas comptable des propos de
l'ensemble des commissaires de la
commission des lois et puis enfin quand
même sur l'aspect intentionnel je crois
qu'il faut être prudent on peut toujours
dire on vote un texte et puis on verra
bien ce que fait le conséquence ionel
il faut quand même attentif puisqu'il ya
quand même quelques temps on a eu le cas
pour les agressions sexuelles où il ya
une qpc qui a fait tomber le dispositif
si votre proposition de loi était voté
en l'état l'article premier quand même à
supprime le fait que les délais pour les
mineurs commencent à courir à partir de
la majorité
donc l article de leur confirme le
conseiller national s'il devait annuler
n'annulerait que l'article 3 et on
serait donc dans la situation où
voilà il y aurait plus y aurait pas
votre dispositif mais il y aurait en
revanche aucun dispositif permettant de
faire courir les délais à partir de la
majorité et donc on reviendrait à une
situation antérieure à
1986 ce qui serait
retour en arrière considérable donc je
crois qu'il faut être extrêmement
méfiant et le risque mentionnés elle a
été pointé par le gouvernement par la
commission des lois donc il faut
peut-être être prudent et voter un
amendement qui ne donne pas complètement
satisfaction mais qui est une avancée et
qui lui ne comporte aucun risque en
matière de continuité
merci le rapporteur madame la ministre à
vis du gouvernement sur cet amendement
si vous voulez bien je donnerais à vis
du gouvernement par un même argumentaire
sur les deux amendements ne sera porteur
puisque sont ils sont ils sont rejoints
dans leur cohérence et leur logique pour
dire d'abord que ces amendements ont
déjà une qualité c'est de me souvenais
de soulever aucun problème de
constitutionnalité
ce que nous tous qui est déjà
les aborder avec un oeil plus confiant
que la proposition de loi simplement
pour faire remarquer que
deux mais c'est à la c'est l'ambiguïté
la difficulté du sujet sur lequel vous
travaillez un madame dini et de trouver
la moins mauvaise solution pour les
victimes et de pas ne pas quand même
minoré ou ignorer le fait que plus on
allonge le délai de prescription
plus là les preuves vont être difficile
à apporter puisque on n'est plus dans
des délais de prescription dans des
délais aussi long dans des preuves
matérielles mais on essentiellement dans
des preuves par témoignages et que au
fur et à mesure que le temps passe et
témoignages sont de plus en plus
difficiles à recueillir et qu'il ne
faudrait pas ajouter pour ses victimes
une deuxième blessure une deuxième
souffrance qui serait celle du
classement sans suite cela celle du
non-lieu et de la difficulté à se faire
rendre justice et qui serait à ce moment
là un deuxième dénis pour les victimes
c'est mais c'est une difficulté qui est
difficile à évaluer parce que autant
autant de tim autant de situations
différentes autant de chemins
psychologique différents et autant de
capacités différentes un faire-valoir
des témoignages et à avoir des idées des
instructions et des actions en justice
qui se conclut différemment donc je
ferai juste attirer votre attention là
dessus et c'est valable aussi pour dans
le cas d'un amendement de monsieur
rapporteur pour dire aussi quand même
attention à la proportionnalité même si
là encore on est dans un
système en vain dérogatoire au droit
commun de la prescription qui en général
qui en principe par des faits là nous ne
partons pas d'effet nous partons de la
victime donc on est dans l'angle de vue
est déplacé mais il faut quand même
garder une proportionnalité mais pour
ces raisons et aussi parce que le
gouvernement est sensible pas sensible
au sens ému mais et dans la démarche que
vous poursuivez et que lui même et dans
une réflexion globale sur les délais de
prescription on ne peut pas traiter
toujours par par sujet et qui appelle à
une réflexion plus cohérente je dis au
nom du gouvernement je me remettrai un
avis de sagesse au sénat sur les deux
amendements de monsieur rapporteur sur
l'allongement du délai de prescription
je vois la sagesse forme et la sagesse
des sénateurs et je sais à quel point
les grandes
merci de votre mémoire madame la
ministre
mes chers collègues des explications de
vote madame dit
il
10dans
il est bien évident que
tout ce qui a été dit montre d'abord
tout l'intérêt que nos collègues portent
à cette question et que cette douleur
des victimes
tout le monde y est sensible
moi je suis sensible monsieur le
rapporteur et madame la ministre
en fait que vous nous proposez une
solution qui n'est pas aussi
complète que celle que j'aurais souhaité
mais vous mettez aussi en avant les
questions d'inconstitutionnalité et il
est certain que si notre texte d'origine
à chantal jouanno est à moi devait être
rejetée nous prendrions le risque de
n'avoir rien du tout alors que notre
souci est de pouvoir aider les victimes
à être elle-même en capacité de
s'exprimer et il est vrai que
l'allongement de 10 ans et de 10 ans
puisque je pense que la réalité on
traite les deux amendes les deux
amendements ensemble est un progrès dont
je suis sûr que les personnes qui
l'attendent ils sont sensibles
vous avez parlé
d'imprescriptibilité
et en aucun cas je ne voudrais faire
enfin j'ai trop de respect pour les
personnes qui ont été victimes de crimes
contre l'humanité pour souhaiter qu'on
puisse
prononcer le mot d'imprescriptibilité
mais je voudrais juste rappeler que dans
les crimes contre l'humanité c'est un
groupe contre un groupe là évidemment
c'est un individu contre un individu
c'est un grand nombre d'individus contre
un grand nombre d'individus et la
question qui peut être mise en parallèle
entre les crimes contre l'humanité et
ces crimes commis contre des personnes
c'est que à ces personnes on a retiré
une partie de leur humanité c'est juste
un
le parallèle qu'on peut faire parce que
dans les crimes de guerre dans les
crimes contre l'humanité on a aussi
souvent avant de retirer la vie retire l
humanité aux personnes donc c'était ce
que je voulais dire sans aller plus loin
parce que bien sûr on ne peut pas j'ai
bien compris m ces prescriptions et
imprescriptibilité sur les violences
sexuelles
je remercie
mes collègues je remercie d'abord
monsieur le rapporteur pour avoir je
dois le dire
pris la très rapidement là
l'importance de du texte qu'on lui
soumettait
parce qu'il a eu des auditions que ça je
crois sall a éclairé c'est là où
convaincu de cette importance je
remercie tous mes collègues qui ont
cosigné cette ce texte et je remercie
aussi tous mes collègues qui m'ont écrit
pour me donner leur soutien c'est donc
que c'est un sujet qui nous intéresse
qui nous touchent et il nous touche
certainement parce que à un moment ou à
l'autre on a pu avoir l'impression que
ça se passait pas très loin de nous
puisque s'il y a autant de prédateur
c'est bien qu'ils sont quelque part et
ce quelque part quelquefois on le
découvre et c'est dramatique pour tout
le monde mais d'abord pour la victime
voilà alors je voulais vous dire que je
voterai les deux amendements du de
monsieur kalt and back
merci madame aider manama que karman
oui comme je les laissais entendre dans
mon intervention général nous allons
nous abstenir sur les trois amendements
de notre rapporteur
je pense que ils ne répondent pas aux
problèmes que nous avons soulevés au
sein de la commission des lois sur le
texte initial de madame dini je pense
que il vise finalement à aller à
l'encontre même des principes dont
montaron ici souvent séance qui font
l'unanimité au sein de la commission des
lois et qui vise à ne pas rallonger pour
rallonger le délai de prescription pour
tous
parce que évidemment tels que c'est
rédigé il concernera les mineurs mais
tous mineurs indépendamment du
traumatisme que vous avez évoqué et que
vous pointez dans le texte de loi
j'attire l'attention des collègues ici
c'est qu'avec ses abonnements nous
changeons complètement la posture du
texte de loi tel qu'il était telle
qu'elle était proposé bien sûr il y
avait des problèmes de reconstitution
était bien sûr il y avait certainement
des choses à revoir et par un certain
nombre de formulation est compris et ça
a été pointée on arrivait
à enlever des garanties présente
aujourd'hui dans la procédure qui ne
l'était plus et donc de cela nous
aurions pu en discuter et leur travail
et mes même dîner je vous le redis si
vous posiez avec ce texte une vraie
question qu'il est plus posée dans le
test texte qui va être voté aujourd'hui
qui était celle que l'agression sexuelle
le viol sur une personne mineure comme
sur une personne majeure peut entraîner
à tel traumatisme de tel et mais
également aussi un tel rapport à ce
qu'est ou ce que n'est pas le viol que
l'on soit mineur ou que l'on soit majeur
que cela implique de s'interroger à
partir de quand le délai de prescription
doit courir on a parlé des mineurs et je
n'y reviendrai pas hélas la souffrance
bien évidemment du mineur tout le monde
la reconnaît la période la minorité
prenons cas des majeures je le disais au
sein d'un mariage
bien sûr on part après delà de la partie
du delà du moment du divorce de la
prononciation du divorce et pour
certaines femmes c'est 15 20 25 ans
après qu'elle se rende compte que
effectivement il y a eu viol dans le
cadre du mariage dans le lit conjugal
il y a aussi les personnes majeures et
je l'évoqué qui peuvent avoir ce
traumatisme et qui plusieurs années
après prennent conscience parce que bon
j'entends la quarantaine pour les
victimes de viols pendant les pendants
les la période de minorités mais il peut
y avoir aussi d'avoir des périodes plus
longues donc vois pas pourquoi plus tard
on la rallonge aurait pas encore un peu
plus et donc tout l'argument qui visait
à détruire la proposition de loi telle
qu'elle était initialement rédigé sur le
fait que s'attendait à
l'imprescriptibilité excusez moi mes
chers collègues mais on tend quand même
à y aller aussi en rallongeant pour
rallonger toujours plus le délai de
prescription limitée donc vraiment moi
je pense que ces amendements là ils peur
leur sens pour une meilleure protection
des mineurs mais en tout cas ils
reviennent je vais peut-être vous
choquer je sais très bien que personne
n'a dit semailles signe au sein de la
commission mais quand même mes chers
collègues sachez qu'une personne majeure
une femme ou un homme majeur qui se fait
vieux et non ce n'est pas vrai qu'en
faisant un petit effort il peut s'en
souvenir dans le délai de prescription
tel qu'il est donnée si on prend le
moment de l'acte voilà parce que si in
fine et c'est quand même ce que
inconsciemment nous sous-entendent on
sert que l'enfant et les mineurs donc
lui effectivement le protège et on
rallonge de 10 ans le délai de
prescription
bien sûr que ça je l'entends et sa
personne n'ose le remettre en cause ici
qui va oser ici dire ça dans la société
d'aujourd'hui bien sûr que cet affreux
mais quand même mes chers collègues
interrogeons-nous pourquoi finalement ne
poussons pas jusqu'au bout ce débat et
je les dis qui dans notre groupe nous
posait aussi problème tels que c'était
rédigé nous pourquoi nous ne poussons
pas jusqu'au bout ce débat à partir de
quand le délai de prescription doit
partir sur la question d'une agression
sexuelle nous n'avons pas poussé
jusqu'au bout parce que quelque part il
nous dérange parce que quelque part
inconsciemment et collectivement une
personne majeure qui se fait violer soit
quelque part elle avec à faire un effort
pour pas se faire violer soit quelque
part c'est fondamentalement impossible
qu'elle ne puisse pas se souvenir
tellement d'ailleurs l'acte et violent
par lui-même et je crois que en
acceptant ces amendements et nous nous
abstiendrons sur ces armements parce que
à bien en votant ses amendements là et
ce texte à la sortie nous n'allons pas
jusqu'au bout de ce débat tech on
entendait le poser donc voila moi
franchement pour toutes ces raisons que
je viens d'évoquer nous abstiendrons
attrait après un échange dans notre
groupe qui nous a beaucoup qui aboutit à
l'abstention du groupe ici en séance
ce qu' ils ne répondent pas là non plus
au problème posé est évoquée dans le
cadre de la ppl initialement
merci la parole est à madame goulet
monsieur le président madame le ministre
mes chers collègues tout à l'heure
chantal jouanno a parlé à la tribune
d'un conflit de loyauté et je trouvais
que c'était absolument opportun et les
amendements qu'ils sont qui sont déposés
pose un conflit de loyauté oui il ya un
problème
oui la ppl initial visait pas à trouver
une solution oui ça nous rappelle nos
cours avec des conduites des conditions
purement potestative qui sont évidemment
réputée non écrite puisque évidemment on
ne peut pas décider soi-même de
condition qu'on a soi-même parents pas
remplir oui oui cette rigueur du droit
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois et est très est très importante
dans cette maison et chantal jouanno l'a
dit et d'autres l'ont dit aussi c'est
vrai que parfois nous en manquons
beaucoup et parfois nous sommes moins
rigoureux sur le caractère non normatif
et bavard de la loi on en a eu un
certain nombre d'exemples ces derniers
jours et dans les mois qui ont précédé
ce n'est pas nouveau et ce conflit de
loyauté là aussi je reprendrai ce qu'a
dit muguette dini et j'aurais dit la
même chose c'est entre l'humanité qu'il
nous faut pour essayer de régler ce
problème et les problèmes
constitutionnels parce qu'on voit bien
ceux qui sont posées alors je crois que
notre haute assemblée à trouver une
solution on va vous avez trouvé une une
cote mal taillée pour régler un certain
nombre de problèmes mais la question
reste entière et je rejoins vraiment ce
que vient de dire notre collègue cécile
kerman je pense que le problème reste
vraiment entier et les amendements que
vous avez déposé nous pose plus de
problèmes qu'il n'en règle parce que on
est obligé de changer de logique et je
ne crois pas que dans l'esprit des
rédacteurs et des cosignataires dont je
fais partie cela fait était vraiment
dans les dents les objectifs en même
temps est ce qu'on peut qu'on peut
prendre le risque de ne pas avoir un
délai de prescription supérieur de 10
ans pour pour les victimes qui en ont
besoin aujourd'hui
je crois que tout ça mérite vraiment
madame le ministre une réflexion très
approfondie ça fait sept ans que je suis
sénateur dans cette maison nous avons
réussi au forceps à avoir quelques
modifications de prescription sur la loi
sur la presse je ne parle pas des abus
de biens sociaux qu'on ne peut pas
toucher ce grand débat sur les
prescriptions et la remise en question
et l'harmonisation des prescriptions est
un problème absolue mais dans le cas qui
nous occupe ici
c'est un problème encore une fois humain
et je n'ai pas encore et je n'ai pas
encore décidé si j'allais m'abstenir ou
voter les amendements du rapporteur
temps ce temps ce sujet et est un sujet
poignant est important et et en même
temps est-ce qu'en restant sur des
principes on ne risque pas de créer
encore plus de victimes et plus de plus
de traumatismes
donc merci
muguette dini merci chantal jouanno nous
avoir proposé ce texte de cette obstiné
sur ce texte parce que c'est quand même
pas la première fois qu'il est présenté
espérons qu'il soit voté dans des termes
peut-être insatisfaisant aujourd'hui et
que surtout à l'assemblée nationale leur
prennent assez vite pour qu'on ait un
peu moins de victimes à déplorer dans
les mois et les années qui viendront
merci madame benbassa
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire lors de la
discussion générale
le groupe écologiste est opposée depuis
longtemps à l'instauration d'un droit
toujours plus d'exceptions et ce en
quelques domaines que ce soit en
l'occurrence
pour ce texte on a l'impression qu'on
attend que la teneur des peines et les
nouveaux délais de prescription empêche
les prédateurs d'agir nous voyons bien
vu les discussions que nous avons eues
dans les groupes nous aussi d'ailleurs
nous avons discuté aussi bien avec les
personnes qui s'occupent dans le parti
de cette question et aussi dans le
groupe au sénat ici jean désessard était
d'accord de voter pour et les autres ont
pris la décision de s'abstenir toutefois
on voit bien que nous sommes désarçonné
face à cette question des violences
sexuelles et d'où toutes ces discussions
or les amendements qui nous sont soumis
ici s'ils ont le mérite de rendre le
dispositif de la proposition de loi plus
acceptable juridiquement j'entends ont
bien pour conséquence de déloger un peu
plus encore aux principes généraux
régissant la prescription de l'action
publique en matière pénale s'ils sont
adoptés et ses amendements auront pour
effet de créer une distinction difficile
à justifier en victimes majeures et
mineures dont je rappelle que le droit
dérogatoire pour ces derniers tiennent
déjà compte à la fois de la gravité des
faits et de la vulnérabilité des
victimes nous sommes prêts à prendre
activement part à tout exclu aurait pour
objectif de remettre à plat l'ensemble
des dispositions relatives à la
prescription de sucroît août le ses
raisons j'aimerais ajouter que le texte
amendé par notre rapporteur malgré ces
efforts qui sont très importants et
louable n'est plus le texte de madame
dénis et jouanno mais un nouveau texte
pour toutes ces raisons le groupe
écologiste outre monsieur jean des
salles s'abstiendra pour cette pour ce
texte
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
à monsieur alain gournac
du président mes chers collègues comme
vous l'avez vu je suis co signataires et
quand le texte est arrivé sur mon bureau
je l' ai tout de suite soutenu
d'ailleurs je me souviens de
conversation et madame dini
qui était quand elle avait la
responsabilité de la commission des
affaires sociales et cette réflexion est
tout à fait d'actualité alors
bien sûr que je suis très ennuyé que
d'autres textes ne puisse pas aboutir
moi je serais d'accord avec madame
jouanno je trouve très bizarre on peut
faire passer mais il y en a qu'un c'est
bizarre hein d'histoire de la poisse
constitutionnel on l a vu l'a
dernièrement d'ailleurs et je réfléchis
je me dis oui c'est plus de texte mais
nous ne pouvons pas rester à rien faire
et que si les amendements de la part de
notre rapporteur
de la commission et de la commission des
lois si nous pouvons obtenir quelque
chose pourquoi ne pas le prendre
puisqu'il faudra quand même un moment
remette tout à plat remette tout à plat
alors c'est un mois je suis aussi comme
madame jouanno il ya quatre ans cinq ans
on a parlé dites-moi ce qu'a avancé
dites-moi ce qu'ils avancent et si
quelque chose avance et venez me voir
ils veulent m expliquer c'est quelque
chose qui brise qui brise des personnes
qui brise des personnes et moi je suis
dans un département où il ya même des
zones où il faut se taire je ne dis pas
ou parce que ce serait pas bien
vis-à-vis mot département on se tait la
famille fait pression pour qu'on se
taise dans dix ans à tort c'est
d'histoire interne c'est d'histoire
interne il faut surtout pas en parler eh
bien les gens sont brisés tout à l'heure
on entendait toutes sortes de réactions
moi je vais plus loin ça brise
la vie des couples ça brise la vie des
couples et on rencontre des difficultés
terribles parce que il ya toujours cette
ce retour donc moi je serai avec la
difficulté je dis la vérité mais j'ai ça
plutôt du côté de d'accepter plutôt que
rien d'accepter parce que c'est rien
après d'accepter les amendements du
rapporteur pour que l'on puisse
progresser là les statistiques ce n'est
pas nous qui inventeront intervient tard
servir car c'est comme ça on lui demande
pourquoi il ils avaient tous deux
possibilités non parce que ça reviens
tard il ya un moment où il ya quelque
chose qui se construit et qui amène à
dire bah moi je me sortir de ça donc
voilà ce que je voulais dire puisque
depuis le départ et je soutiens ce que
nous faisons aujourd'hui
merci chers coller la parole et à madame
chantal jouanno
merci monsieur le président merci
beaucoup
cette explication vaudra d'ailleurs pour
tout le texte simplement trois choses la
première madame la ministre c'est que
cette proposition de loi s'inscrit dans
le cadre d'un plan plus général que nous
vous proposerons sur les violences
sexuelles qui travaillent effectivement
comme le rappelle rappelé madame dîner
avec l'association stop aux violences
sexuelles qui vise à éradiquer cette
ce problème qui peut être considéré
comme une forme d'épidémie et donc à
traiter aussi bien les agresseurs que
les victimes deuxième élément monsieur
le rapporteur je ne ferai pas je ne
voterai pas contre vos amendements
parce que ils sont empreints de bonne
volonté parce que cette mieux
effectivement que de revenir à la
situation existante et que connaissant
le travail parlementaire et
gouvernementale
je sais très bien qu'on peut vous battre
ici qu'on peut battre le gouvernement
mais qui in fine est de toute façon ça
ne prospérera pas là au moins on a une
chance que sa prospère et que le texte
législatif poursuivre sa navette pour
autant je ne voterai pas pour parce que
comme ça a été rappelé c'est aussi une
forme de négation finalement du
phénomène de la les post traumatique et
donc de la violence que constituent ces
violences sexuelles ces viols sur les
personnes et tout particulièrement
effectivement sur les mineurs alors y
compris évidemment au sein des coupes
mais sur les mineurs c'est absolument
destructeur ça a été rappelé plusieurs
fois les victimes parlent de torture au
sens au sens propre du terme par
conséquent je ne pourrai pas voter pour
et je m'abstiendrai je vous remercie
merci chers collègues je n'ai pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
je vais donc mettre voir cet amendement
numéro deux avec le vif donc
l'amendement de la commission invite
sagesse du gouvernement qui pour
contre
abstentions
l'amendement est adopté je mets donc on
voit et l'article 1er est ainsi rédigé
sur l'article 2 l'amendement numéro 3
monsieur quaterback
c'est un moment qui est dans la droite
ligne du premier amendement et qui vise
à porter le délai de dix à vingt ans
pour les agressions sexuelles donc c'est
comblement cohérent avec le dispositif
je voudrais en profiter pour répondre à
quelques interventions c'est vrai que
l'amendement que j'ai proposé ne change
pas la logique actuelle sur laquelle est
construite
le système de délai de prescription en
france depuis 2007 le sénat demande à ce
que tout soit mis à plat et qu'il y ait
un vaste débat et un nouveau texte de
loi j'espère que ça viendra rapidement à
l'ordre du jour mais encore faudrait-il
que le gouvernement en est la volonté
quoi qu'il en soit c'est vrai qu'il
faudra à un moment ou un autre qu'on en
passe par un débat sur les délais de
prescription le point de départ et la
durée pour les différents délits et
crimes mais voilà aujourd'hui on est
saisi d'un point précis les violences
sexuelles et spécifiquement sur les
mineurs et là je vous réponde à madame
kuperman j'ai traité c'est vrai que
l'aspect mineur parce que des auditions
que j'ai eu c'est principalement là
dessus que
mon attention a été attirée après c'est
une proposition de loi qui n'a pas
forcément vocation à régler toutes les
questions liées aux violences faites aux
mineurs ou aux femmes bien évidemment
d'ailleurs le gouvernement travaille sur
un prix aux hommes aussi bien sûr le
gouvernement travaille sur un plan pour
lutter justement contre les violences
faites aux femmes et aux hommes avec des
textes de lois qui sont en préparation
il faudrait sûrement également qu'il y
ait un plan d'action pour mieux protéger
nos enfants aujourd'hui donc tout ça
doit être débattue dans un cadre plus
large mais là on est quand même sur une
proposition de loi de trois articles qui
concernait un point spécifique les
délais de prescription c'est un sujet
important mais qui doit bien sûr
s'intégrer dans une réflexion et un
dispositif beaucoup plus large je sais
que le gouvernement il est très
sensibilisée et
la ministre rossignol fera écho de nos
débats auprès notamment de madame
belkacem qui suit de près ces sujets et
j'ai eu l'occasion d'auditions au nez
des membres de son ministère voilà c'est
une première étape et bien évidemment il
faudra aller plus loin à la fois contre
toutes ces violences faites aux adultes
et aux enfants et puis également sur
l'aspect de la mise à plat des délais de
prescription et de leur point de départ
mais je crois qu'il faut en effet
aujourd'hui tenir compte du fait que le
système est construit avec une
architecture et s'intégrer dans cette
architecture lors du débat général
peut-être doit-il revoir le point de
départ de la prescription mais attendons
d'avoir ce débat sur un texte général
sur les prescriptions ainsi monsieur le
rapporteur madame la ministre avait
compris que vous alliez donner un avis
de sagesse également sur cet amendement
pas d'explications de vote je veux voir
qui est pour
quand
abstention l'article 2 est ainsi rédigé
sur l'article 3 l'amendement numéro 4
monsieur le rapporteur
c'est purement un amendement de
cohérence avec les deux premiers
je vais mettre voix pour
contre
abstentions
l'article est supprimé
l'article 4 donc même voiture l'article
4 ème bottes et je vais mettre voir mes
chers collègues l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi y at-il des
explications de vote magisto
annonce vous votiez
excusez moi j'avais compris que quand
vous voulez une explication de vote
alors vous avez la parole j'avais bien
compris
merci merci monsieur le président je
veux remercier les auteurs de la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
madame dit ni madame jouanno en effet
elle nous oblige à regarder en face la
situation de femmes le plus souvent mais
aussi d'inde hommes qui ont vécu là
soutenable l'indicible dès lors qu'il
s'agit de viols d'agressions sexuelles
je les remercie de leur détermination de
la pudeur avec laquelle nous ont obligés
à la réflexion mais aussi à la nécessité
d'être force de proposition au regard de
la législation actuelle nos collègues
nous interpelle sur une question
juridique le délai de prescription en
décrivant avec humanité les conséquences
des viols des agressions sexuelles
le meurtre de l'âme exprime le docteur
violaine guéri guérin médecins
gynécologues endocrinologues
des situations terriblement fréquentes
près de 400 mille cas qui restent en
deux ans qui restent trop souvent
secrets de conscience secrets de famille
vous l'avez dit madame la ministre l'écu
par les enfants avec des conséquences
pour les adultes physique psychique qui
ne guérit jamais et qui se caractérisent
souvent par une amnésie traumat post
traumatique une cécité psychique parce
que c'est bly sur son vécu dans la
famille dans l'entourage proche le plus
souvent dans l'intimité de vie de la
victime ses blessures sont insoutenables
à regarder pour soi même avec très
souvent un profond sentiment de
culpabilité
face à ces traumatismes de la vie si
profonde je veux remercier notre
rapporteur qui au-delà d'arguments
juridiques imparable concernant la
législation actuelle sur le délai de
prescription il ya eu un vaste débat sur
la question et les arguments qui ont été
entendus sont difficilement et
quelquefois entendable car ceux qui ne
sont pas spécialistes de comment dire du
discours juridique mais notre rapporteur
à proposer par voie d'amendement une
proposition qui améliore le délai
pendant lesquelles des victimes pourront
porter plainte pour sanction pour que
sanction réparation soit faite mais
aussi pour permettre que le prédateur
n'agissent plus quand il est encore
vivant
la réponse juridique apportée est
imparfaite je crois qu'on l'a tous dit
elle ne clôt pas le débat je crois que
le débat reste totalement d'actualité et
je sais madame la ministre votre
détermination à traiter du sujet des
violences faites aux femmes je pense que
au delà du côté sans doute un parfait la
réponse est néanmoins un progrès et je
voterai cette proposition de loi ainsi
amendé et nous et le groupe socialiste
la votera mais je pense qu'au nom de
notre groupe d'autres s'expriment roues
merci chers collègues y at il d'autres
explications de vote non je vais donc
mettre voit l'ensemble de la proposition
de loi modifiant le délai de
prescription de l'action publique des
agressions sexuelles qui est favorable
je vous remercie qui est contre
merci qui s'abstient
merci chers collègues le sénat a adopté
cette proposition de loi voilà pour
l'adoption de cette proposition de loi
sur la prescription des agressions
sexuelles on y revient tout de suite
dans 24heures sénat le journal